[Music]
in 1936 at the berlin olympic games in
germany adolf hitler witnessed american
sprinter jesse owens son of a
sharecropper grandson of a slave win
four gold medals
next on book tv jeremy schapp on his new
book triumph the untold story of jesse
owens and hitler's olympics from the
university of buffalo in new york this
is an hour
this is your npr station 887 wbfo public
radio from ub this is meet the author
and i'm bert gambinny tonight's show
coming to you from the student union
theater on the university at buffalo
north campus a program made possible in
part by ub's division of student affairs
and our media co-sponsor
buffalorising.com
we'd also like to welcome a crew from
c-span here to tape tonight's visit for
later broadcast as part of its book tv
presentation
our meet the author guest tonight is
jeremy schapp and this month's selection
is his new book triumph the untold story
of jesse owens and hitler's olympics
jesse owens performance in berlin more
than 70 years ago ranks among the
greatest achievements in sports history
it is also one of the great ironies in
sports history that those achievements
were as much about refuting a national
agenda as defeating opponents all in an
environment which was supposed to be
devoid of politics
as the games approached the germans
carefully and insidiously concealed the
signs of hatred as they made promises of
fairness that they had no intention of
keeping
in the u.s many believed that american
athletes should not be part of such an
obvious nazi propaganda vehicle
that boycott effort did not succeed
jesse owens did
and before the summer of 1936 was over
america's greatest hero as famous as
anyone in the country
who single-handedly crushed the nazi
notion of racial superiority at the same
time he confronted racial prejudice at
home
would be stripped of his amateur status
when exhausted and broke he withdrew
from the final leg of an aau exhibition
tour
owens trained as an athlete but the
circumstances and the stage pushed him
in other directions social and political
i'm looking forward to exploring those
directions and exploring this story
tonight with our guest the author of the
new book triumph the untold story of
jesse owens and hitler's olympics
please join me now in welcoming to wbfo
and the university at buffalo our meet
the author guest jeremy schapp
thank you bert
jeremy i'd like to open the the program
by asking you to uh to read from the
book if you will specifically the the
prologue which really sets the scene for
uh for later discussion uh my pleasure
um
i i shall begin uh
just before 9 30 p.m central time on
september 23 1955 in a handsome
townhouse on chicago's south side james
cleveland owen slipped into a tweed
jacket and sat down in a straight back
chair as he smoothed out his pencil
mustache and slicked back his hair what
little was left left of it a dozen
technicians put the finishing touches on
what had been an all-day job wiring and
lighting the owens home in a few minutes
owens would be talking live on national
tv with edward armor of cbs on his
celebrity interview show
person-to-person more than 20 million
americans would watch as moro spoke from
a studio in new york first with owens
and his family and then in the second
half of the show with leonard bernstein
and his
a 42-year-old father of three jesse
owens weighed 25 pounds more than he had
in berlin in 1936
when he turned in the most indelible
performance ever at the olympic games
in his conservative jacket flannel
slacks white shirt and dark tie he could
have passed for a 50 year old not that
he wasn't in superb shape he was in fact
just a few months earlier he had run 100
yards in 9.9 seconds
less than a second slower than his
personal best he still held the world
record in both the broad jump now called
the long jump and the four by 100 meter
relay though both records had been set
in the mid 1930s for his part murrow was
readying himself for another half hour
banalities
no one confused person to person
would see it now moro's other show on
cbs the one on which 18 months earlier
he had neutered senator joseph mccarthy
despite the fluff murrow was eager to
speak with no with owens whose legend
had grown significantly since 1936.
here murrow thought was a legitimate
american hero the man who had humbled
the third reich
for owens the appearance with murrow was
emblematic of his enhanced stature in
the 15 years since his athletic career
ended he had struggled to find his way
professionally and financially he'd made
more money than the vast majority of his
fellow americans in the dry cleaning
business at ford motors working for the
state of illinois
but the windfall he expected in the
aftermath of his olympic heroics never
materialized
banned from amateur competition after an
umbrolio with american track officials
he'd raced against horses most famously
in havana in december 1936 defeating
julio mccaw a five-year-old bay gelding
after the horse spotted him a 40-yard
advantage in 1938 on the occasion of the
first night baseball game at evans field
he raced two speedy major league
outfielders spotting them several yards
he barnstormed with a black baseball
team and campaigned for the republican
presidential candidate alf landon
in countless ways he had sold himself
but he never had much to show for it
until now
by the time owen sat down to speak with
muro he was well on his way to becoming
an institution to jesse owens who would
spend the rest of his life telling his
story to appreciative audiences around
the world the jesse owens who could have
been a hero from horatio alger if
alger's heroes had not all been white
in the years after his olympic victories
his achievements in berlin had been
overshadowed by world war ii but by 1955
at the end of the first decade of the
cold war he was finally getting his due
he was in demand as a banquet speaker
and making good money because he had
become useful to industry and government
as a symbol of the opportunity amer the
opportunities america promised and
sometimes delivered
to the delight of white america and most
of black america he disputed the
sentiments of paul robeson the
all-american football player turned
actor singer who famously suggested that
african americans would not and should
not fight for the united states in the
event of war with the soviet union
owens in contrast held himself out as an
example of what black americans could
achieve despite the indignities and
slights he had suffered his entire life
he agreed with jackie robinson who in
his 1949 testimony before the house on
american activities committee had said
that blacks had too much invested in the
american experiment to support its
enemies
just a few days after his appearance on
person-to-person owens was to embark at
the behest of the state department on a
goodwill goodwill tour of singapore
malaya the philippines and india as am
rosenthal then the new york times
correspondent in south asia put it
owens's mission was to make friends for
the united states having fought the
fascist the fascists with his fleetness
of foot he would now fight the
communists with his charm and rhetoric
even though some indian writers unversed
in the annals of the olympics confused
him with sir owen dixon an australian
judge in united nations mediator
before the long ride to the subcontinent
though there was the interview with
murrow whose fondness for bespoke
tailoring matched his own
finally at 9 30 with a cigarette
clenched in his left hand murrow began
the interview
jesse owens he said is generally
recognized as the greatest track star of
the last half century his performance in
berlin stands unmatched in modern times
statistics will never indicate adolf
hitler's reaction as he watched a 23
year old boy from danville alabama run
the athletes of the master race right
into the ground
owens whose politeness was among his
defining characteristics declined to
crack muro by pointing out that he had
been 22 not 23 and was from oakville
alabama not danville he simply smiled
and waited for the questions he knew
were coming the questions that always
came
after several minutes of amiable chatter
you look to be in almost good enough
condition to get out your old track
shoes again
and the introduction of owens's wife and
three pretty daughters moreau offered
him the opportunity to talk about the
games of the 11th olympiad
jesse owens he said what's your warmest
memory of that august of 1936
owens had been asked that question or
its variance perhaps hundreds of times
he did not hesitate
i remember a boy he said his accent
portraying no hint of his southern roots
that i competed against in the broad
jump a boy with whom i built a
friendship and we corresponded for a
number of years and then the war broke
out and i didn't hear any more from him
at all
owens looked down and away from the
camera the boy he was referring to was
lutz long the silver medalist a pure
blooded aryan from leipzig who'd helped
him reach the broad jump finals when
he'd been on the verge of
disqualification
composing himself owens talked about
long sun kai owens and kai had met in
1951 and then about winning the 100
meter dash but he had not yet answered
morrow's question
i think that the greatest moment that a
person can have is to stand on a victory
stand he said far away from home and
then from the distance you can hear the
strains of the star-spangled banner and
then suddenly you make a left turn and
you see the stars and stripes rising
higher and higher and the higher the
stars and stripes rose the louder the
strains of the star-spangled banner
would be heard i think that's the
greatest moment of my whole athletic
career
as the crew finally moved his couch and
coffee table back where they belonged
into the deep indentations in the carpet
owens and his wife ruth carefully return
his memorabilia to display case a few
special items had been freed from the
case temporarily for murrow and his
audience to see clearly they were there
were the bronze spikes and the metals
the laurel wreaths all the tokens of his
youthful greatness he had collected them
19 years earlier in germany with the
eyes of the world fixed on him in an
atmosphere charged by an ascendant third
reich on a continent that would soon
confuse convulse in war and genocide
nothing just jesse owens did at the
olympic stadium diminish the horrors to
come he saved no lives however for those
paying close enough attention owens and
berlin revealed essential truths while
the western democracies were perfecting
the art of appeasement while much of the
rest of the world cow towed to the nazis
owens stood up to them at their own
olympics refuting their venomous
theories with his awesome deeds
as jeremy shep reading from the prologue
of his new book our meet the author
selection for this month triumph the
untold story of jesse owens and hitler's
olympics
jeremy to begin if we look at the place
that track and field held in the minds
of american sports fans in the 1930s
it's a very different place from what
the sport holds today for american
sports fans well track and field today
is in many ways in the u.s uh dead sport
uh people barely pay attention
i think there are a few factors at play
um
first of all the drug scandals that have
rocked the sport going back to even
before ben johnson in 1988 the canadian
gold medalist in seoul who tested
positive for steroids and was stripped
of the gold medal
but i think it's a sport that
in many ways
was
most attractive to americans when this
was a more rural society uh running and
jumping field events those were the
things that that i think young people
did when they were living away from
cities when they had room to run and to
play in that way and in that way it's a
lot like
harness racing which the turn of the
20th century was among our most popular
sports and now
you'd be hard-pressed to find any
coverage of it in the mainstream press
uh it was linked
indelibly to to this country's rural
roots
and in the 1930s when jesse owens
was was competing
it was up there with baseball
horse racing
and college football as the preeminent
sports
um
thousands of people showed up to see
jesse owens compete
when he uh broke a whole bunch of world
records at a famous meet in 1935 it was
front page news
everywhere uh figures such as will
rogers uh wrote about him every day in
the papers his achievement
was uh recognized universally he became
an overnight sensation and familiar to
almost everyone and even as recently as
1950
the associated press polled
393 sports writers for their definitive
mid-century sports poll
and asked them to name the most
significant athlete of the first half of
the 20th century
six of the top 18
were track stars
more than in any other sport if we were
to do such a poll for the last 50 years
of 393 sports writers
if we came up with
one track star in the top 18 carl lewis
i might be surprised you mentioned
certainly not more you mentioned that
meet in 35 36 certainly cemented his um
his celebrity and his uh his place in
history but his athletic reputation at
least the cornerstone of his athletic
reputation was really laid at that meet
in ann arbor in 1935.
it is it's it's um
what he achieves in ann arbor at the big
ten championships on may 25th 1935 and
that's the starting point for me in the
book after the prologue
uh it's so remarkable that um
people i respect sports historians
people that i know who really care about
the history of sport are familiar with
the great moments
still many of them consider it the
greatest
single day accomplishment ever uh i mean
you think about anything anybody has
done will chamberlain scoring 100 points
in hershey pennsylvania um
uh you know uh lou gehrig hitting four
home runs in a single game
reggie jackson hitting three home runs
and consecutive pitches in the 1977
world series jesse owens the big ten
championships in ann arbor
with a sore back
uh he had spent the night before the
finals getting rubbed downs hot tubs he
had fallen down the stairs
fooling around at his fraternity house
at ohio state with some friends he gets
out onto the track
and in the space of less than an hour
uh there's some dispute whether it was
55 minutes or 45 minutes but it was
pretty clearly less than an hour
he
breaks five world records and ties
another
in four different events
in the 100 yard dash the 220 yard dash
the 220 yard hurdles and the broad jump
uh
there
the records are almost all of them
remarkably durable
in fact the broad jump record he sets he
jumps 26 feet eight and a quarter inches
uh which is more than which is half a
foot farther than any human being has
ever previously leaked uh farther than
he would ever again leap and the world
record until
1959.
you mentioned that he's at his athletic
peak in ann arbor yet he's still
improving in many ways in what ways was
he improving he he's not um
he believe it or not
as great as he was and jesse owens is a
guy who's been a star since he was in
high school
he's he's had remarkable times that made
him among the fastest people in the
world since he's 17 years old 18 years
old in high school uh but he never had a
good start
he was uh
he just couldn't quite get out of the
blocks there weren't actually blocks
most of the time when he was racing it
was it was a relatively recent
innovation uh but he couldn't get a
quick start and
um over the course of the next few
months it became it becomes a major
national even international story
uh that jesse owens can be beaten
because
he's not great at getting a good start
in a race and that's why
as great as he was at 100 yards and its
metric equivalent 100 meters and all the
records he said at those distances uh he
was a much stronger
200 meter 220 yard sprinter because over
the
length of that distance you could
compensate for whatever uh poor start
you might have had and and how much of
this story how much of the jesse owens
story is tied to his relationship with
good coaches
i think a lot of it i mean uh
there are two uh
two coaches in his life there is the
coach who discovers him uh when he's in
elementary school even before he gets to
junior high school
um
charles riley
who is uh you know i've got this picture
of him in my mind from having you know
researched him and seen photographs of
him
he's 50 years old when he first sees
jesse owens but he looks like he's 70.
he's got white hair he's extremely frail
he's short he weighs maybe a hundred
pounds
um he he grew up
first generation uh son of immigrants uh
from ireland uh grew up in mock chunk
pennsylvania which was uh a mining town
but known at the turn of the 20th
century as the switzerland of america
the richest town in the u.s because it
had such a high percentage of
millionaires from the mining industry
um he was not from
the rich side of town
and he spots and jesse owens literally
as he's running around the schoolyard
this remarkable talent uh he's a huge
sports enthusiast he loves track in
particular in horse racing
and his own sons have not fulfilled
his ambitions athletically
for them and he becomes a father figure
to jesse owens he becomes the first
white man really
uh who who embraces who jesse sees is
colorblind and jesse meets him
shortly after the family has made the
great trek northward from from alabama
to cleveland
uh and
he retains this relationship
with riley throughout his adolescence in
young adulthood and all the way in fact
through the olympics and then his other
coach is the coach
who guides him at ohio state larry
snyder who if charles riley is a father
figure uh larry snyder's really like a
big brother he he's
only about 15 years older than jesse he
competed at ohio state himself
he's uh an altogether different kind of
uh influence on him but significant
nevertheless one of the things that
larry snyder did too was make sure that
that jesse owens was team captain at
ohio state this at a time when african
americans were not even allowed to live
on campus how unusual was that
distinction oh very he was the first
african-american captain of any team at
ohio state uh of course it would have
been ludicrous to have anyone else
elected team captain after what
the things that jesse achieved but
nevertheless he couldn't live on campus
columbus
ohio
obviously where ohio state is situated
was far from a bastion of
progressiveness
and and jesse was such a highly
respected teenage athlete that the issue
of where he was going to attend college
was something debated uh in the black
press and many uh many observers thought
he should go to a school that had
displayed some progressivism
some said he should go to an
historically black school
ultimately jesse goes to ohio state
because they find a way to help
locate a job for his father they find
him a job there's no such thing really
as an athletic scholarship then he has
to you know work odd jobs to make ends
meet he's already
a father at this point
but he goes to ohio state and as much as
he's living a segregated life there away
from the main body of the campus and
away from the white student body uh
larry snyder makes every effort to
integrate him and his other great
competitor uh
on his team david albritton jesse's best
friend going back to junior high school
on the team and to make them feel
welcome
when
when jesse owens in college
competes against usc which was a track
powerhouse and again this after the the
ann arbor meet the associated press
refers to him as the super athlete of
modern times is this debatable in 1935
given the rise of joe lewis
um
well
you got to remember at this time i i i
don't think that uh when people um after
ann arbor uh
you know the records he said what he's
achieved there in under an hour
has made him this phenomenon and the
laurels are thrown at him from every
corner uh he starts reading the
clippings himself he follows up on that
performance with
a series of similarly spectacular and
dominant performances uh
he is at this point
though only the second most popular
african-american athlete in the country
because joe lewis is is
is this undefeated heavyweight
phenomenon and he's coming along at a
time
uh in boxing when the heavyweight
division has been bereft of a true
superstar since uh gene tunney's
retirement uh
in 1928
and so a lot of people are extremely
enthusiastic about joe lewis
particularly of course the black
community uh and even the white
community embraces joe lewis certainly
in a way that jack johnson who was an
athlete of black america wasn't embraced
but joe lewis hasn't won the
championship yet um
you know it would it would be hard to
call him
the super athlete of modern times or any
other since he's he's at this point an
undefeated challenger spectacular
challenger expected to shortly win the
championship uh which in fact doesn't
happen of course uh but owens is already
the best in the world at what he does in
a sport which matters a great deal to
many millions of americans and and what
about rivals on the track itself was
euless peacock in the same class as
jesse owens well that that's the amazing
thing about jesse owens is summer of
1935
uh you know kind of begins with ann
arbor with this spectacular achievement
the six records
and then he goes to the west coast he
wins
nine out of nine events in which he's
entered in the sprints and the jumps
he dominates the ncaa championships he
dominates the dual meet with usc
um
but then you know his personal life
starts to intrude uh
he he realizes pretty quickly that being
a celebrity has some drawbacks uh in
particular he's he's uh kind of exposed
for courting
a beautiful young woman in in los
angeles while he's out there this at the
same time that he has a fiancee and a
child back in cleveland
there are threats made of breach of
promised suits
and so by the time he gets the aau
championships a few weeks later in
nebraska
he can't concentrate anymore and he ends
up
losing badly there in the sprints uh he
finishes third behind a fellow named
euless peacock and a great olympic
champion named ralph metcalf
he loses the long jump as well which was
unthinkable to euless peacock euless
peacock goes on to beat him
in four consecutive
sprints
uh and peacock's
totally different than jesse i mean
physically owens is
he's this beautiful you know young guy
he's he's light he's 510 he's 160 pounds
he's perfectly proportioned euless
peacock is a football player he's taller
he's stronger he's thicker and
uh as peacock starts beating him race
after race after race and owens is
clearly fatigued and some of the writers
recognize that
other people uh including charlie
paddock who had been the great american
sprinter of the 1920s says you know what
peacock's got his number
uh you know owens goes from being this
spectacular
betting favorite in every event in the
olympics to being uh downgraded to long
shot after peacock uh defeats him in
several occasions
and
you know
every sports columnist in the country
the way you know today they're writing
about
tara owens or john amichy coming out of
the closet this is the way they were
talking about jesse owens losing race
after race everybody writing about it
and owens himself is quoted as saying
boy you know i think i peaked in may
euless just seems to be getting stronger
and stronger i don't think i can keep up
with him
and there were serious analyses done of
whose start was better who was going to
win this who was going to win that so
euless peacock was in every way
a very very serious challenge for owens
you're listening to meet the author this
is your npr station 88 7 fm wbfo we're
working from the student union theater
and the university at buffalo north
campus this evening our guest is jeremy
schapp and our meet the author selection
his new book triumph the untold story of
jesse owens and hitler's olympics
buffalorising.com the city's monthly
print magazine and daily website is
proud to support programming on wbfo
buffalorising.com covers current events
lifestyle trends and civic issues with
local content that celebrates buffalo
and our citizens available at retail
locations throughout the city and also
available online at buffalorising.com
if there was a real threat to jesse
owens olympic prospects it was not just
euless peacock but it was a growing
boycott movement that had been gaining
strength over the last couple of years
is this the first time that that
politics had really intruded upon the
modern games
well
it it
it was i mean except in the sense
obviously there were no olympics uh in
1916 because of the first world war um
that that exception aside uh i would say
so
in
to the best of my knowledge it was the
first time there was serious talk of a
boycott and the boycott talk wasn't just
in the u.s but in great britain in
france around the world there were
a lot of democracies debating the idea
of whether to
to participate in the olympics taking
place uh in hitler's germany um
the debate made more complicated by the
fact the games were awarded to germany
in 1931 before hitler came to power
and people had to you know kind of take
a wait and see approach as to what was
going to happen
but by 1934 only a year into
uh
into hitler's reign
it was apparent to enough people that
what was going on over there was was
intolerable
and uh
there were many many millions of people
around the world who fought very hard to
see their respective countries boycott
the games of the 11th olympiad and the
winter games which were also taking
place in germany in 1936 the
fourth olympic winter games
but uh
you know it became a very very heated
political discussion and there were a
lot of nuances to it and again it's a
story that i think people don't really
remember at all everybody knows of
course the us didn't go to moscow in
1980 and the soviets subsequently
boycotted los angeles and there were
various boycott
boycotts and boycott threats involving
south africa's participation the games
later on but this is this is uh in many
ways the beginning of the politization
politicization of the games who was
behind the boycott effort in the u.s the
boycott effort in the u.s uh
surprisingly isn't uh
engineered by
a jewish politician or a jewish
industrialist or it's engineered by
an irish catholic tammany hall
politician named jeremiah t mahoney
who also happened to be
the
president of the amateur athletic union
which at the time was responsible for
certifying america's olympic athletes
there's an american olympic committee
which pays for the trip and
is officially the us representative at
the in the olympic
community but the aau
actually certifies the athletes conducts
the trials he is the president of the
aau he's uh
an accomplished athlete himself uh he is
much uh he he could have been a hero
from horatio alger
himself very you know born to irish
immigrants worked himself through
nyu and nyu law school became a
prominent judge and really worked
throughout his life uh
to um combat racism and bigotry
uh and his foil
in this debate is the former head of the
aau and the current head of the american
olympic committee avery brundage who's
got a remarkably similar rags to rich's
story but comes at it from a totally
different perspective what about moving
the games was moving the games ever
considered
moving the games uh was considered it
did come up on several occasions uh
there were some of the choices well
interestingly enough the two nations
most eager to host the games if they
were taken away from germany
were fascist italy and fascist japan
which should have given people some
indication that you know there was more
if tojo and mussolini and hitler all
wanted the same thing he had to start
wondering about motives
[Music]
and they uh they campaigned quite
brazenly
actually to get the games relocated the
games in 1940 were supposed to be in
tokyo anyway
uh
eventually
1937 they take the games away from tokyo
and after uh the invasion of china and
they they award them to helsinki of
course those games never took place
either uh but but there were plans afoot
and there were also plans
um
for so-called people's games in
barcelona
which the republican forces
i shouldn't say the republican forces
but uh
those people who favor the republican
side
in the spanish civil war which was just
getting underway uh were behind
brundage ended up touring uh germany as
the uh the boycott debate was going on
what was that tour like and and what did
he learn if anything well brundage was
predisposed to
what happened was the boycott
movement got so far and there was so
much political will behind it not just
mahoney but nine governors numerous u.s
senators
congressmen some of the most prominent
citizens the country that brundage was
forced from a public relations
perspective to go to germany
for uh it's essentially an inspection
tour to see if the germans were
in fact and the issue was how they were
treating not only their jewish citizenry
but more to the point if they were
affording german jewish athletes a
genuine opportunity to compete for their
olympic teams so brundage goes on this
fact-finding mission but
he'd already written a letter
to a publication suggesting that he was
predisposed to giving germany the
benefit of the doubt and it's pretty
clear that avery brundage went who ends
up being the most powerful person ever
in amateur athletics uh as the head of
the international olympic committee was
was a racist uh he was an anti-semite
and and
he was germanophile he he ends up later
life in fact marrying a german woman and
spending a great deal of his life in
germany and dying in germany what was
the what was the the motivation for
brundage in getting a team
to berlin for the games when when the
signs of discrimination were so obvious
the nuremberg laws had had taken effect
uh german jews were were stripped of
their citizenship there was not a jewish
athlete on on the german team yet there
was this intense motivation one one
jewish one on the winner team and one on
the summer team what was the motivation
for getting the us team to berlin why
was it so important if the obvious
injustice was was there well he was i
mean
well he was remarkably stubborn
and he didn't want to see anything
intrude on the olympics i think that
he was he was i
there are people who described him
better than i'm describing him now he
was he was remarkably intransigent
and pigheaded
um and that was really his great
strength and um
he he was principled in his in his own
way
and he
he couldn't see that it was the germans
who were turning these games into a
political propaganda spectacle he could
only see that the people who wanted to
prevent the games from being a success
were turning it into politics and and to
him
you know he always stood fast i mean
you know if avery brundage were alive
today and he saw what the olympics had
become the
commercialization of the games uh you
know he he'd be appalled and some of
that you could say is admirable um and
he wasn't like a lot of the
amateur officials who simply didn't want
to see the rich kids compete
i mean the rich the poor kids compete
against the rich kids he had been a poor
kid himself but he he really believed in
this
this idea of the games must go on
and that's that's more than anything
else is epitaph he's the head of the
international olympic committee at the
massacre in 1972 in munich and the most
famous
four words he ever uttered five words
five words or the games must go on in
the aftermath the massacre and that was
his attitude very much in 1932
it's still 1935 as the debate is going
on and you do point this out in the book
no one could have foreseen the horrors
that were awaiting european jury yet as
the subject of german discrimination
against jewish athletes was being
discussed was anyone in the press
talking about discrimination against
african americans in this country well
that's that's the great uh you know
irony to the whole thing um you know the
jesse owens story has been distilled
for such a long time 70 years you know
kind of the cliff notes version you know
grandson of slaves son of share cropper
goes to hitler's germany refutes
theories of aryan supremacy
gets his four gold medals end of story
uh but he was of course at the same time
a second-class citizen here in the u.s
um
there were so many opportunities denied
to him at that time that it's much more
complex than that
and
the boycott debate
is really
interesting in the sense that
you've got some very principled
well-intentioned
americans saying
we cannot go to hitler's germany in any
way help legitimize this holy evil
regime while at the same time other
people pointed out jesse owens couldn't
check into hotels in
almost virtu in virtually any american
city not just the deep south he couldn't
eat in the same restaurants with white
americans he couldn't live in the same
dorms at ohio state university as his
white teammates
so
the argument struck some obviously as
the height of hypocrisy not just black
americans but you're telling
you're telling us we can't go to
hitler's germany because of the way he's
treating this minuscule jewish
minority
and yet look at the way we're treating
our black minority so you know this was
a debate that went back and forth
did the athletes weigh in this uh you
know collectively and owens in
particular how did they feel about this
debate
well owens initially
jesse jesse again he's only 22 years old
as this debate is really um taking shape
and i think jesse um
the first time he's asked about it he
says well if that's if what you say is
true and they're really treating the
jews as poorly as you say we shouldn't
be in germany we shouldn't be over there
we shouldn't be supporting their economy
we shouldn't be giving them this
opportunity uh this propaganda
opportunity
but then larry snyder essentially pulls
him aside and this is all there in the
contemporaneous accounts and tells him
jesse what are you crazy
you want a boycott
this is your chance this is your only
chance especially as a black american
how else are you going to make an
adequate living to support your family
how else are you going to
um
rise uh to position society better than
your father and your grandfather and
your aunts and your uncles you have to
go to the olympics and you are going to
support
uh the anti-boycott
forces
and and besides you know
what difference is it going to make the
games are going to be there anyway
this is the argument jesse listens to
and at the same time he gets impassioned
please from
people in the boycott community
including the head of the naacp walter
white who writes him this incredibly
touching letter
um beseeching him not to go to the
olympics stating
in essence that
uh bigotry anywhere is intolerable
and you should not
in any way condone it even with your
presence even passively just by
attending the games
um
and jesse listens to the pleas and like
virtually every other athlete who had a
chance of being on the olympic team
rejects them
because
essentially uh that's what athletes do
they they want to compete the only there
were jewish track stars uh who competed
in berlin or did not compete but went on
the team to berlin um
and also jesse recognized at some level
that you know if they say that we're
sub-human and they are the master race
how am i going to disprove that if i'm
not there
but i i don't think that was
that was foremost in his thought process
foremost was i'm an athlete i compete
that's what i do and this is my chance
this is your npr station you're
listening to wbfo public radio from ub
working tonight from the student union
theater on the university at buffalo
north campus i want to invite some of
the audience and get the audience uh
involved in our discussion please your
question from jeremy shap what do you
think gave jesse his perseverance giving
unsurmountable odds um in hitler's
viewpoint
what what gave him that perseverance
during this time
um
i i think
owens is uh he's remarkably cool under
pressure
he's been in pressure-packed situations
before
he was one of these guys who
found a way
always to rise to the occasion
i think his uh his coaches larry snyder
and charles riley were very important in
that regard and i think his mother
was very very important in that regard
as well uh she had instilled in him from
a very early age
uh
the notion that he could be special
and he was one of ten children there was
no reason to believe uh that he would be
able to fulfill her hopes for him
but but she she really did
i think at a very early stage in his
life give him a confidence that remained
with him throughout
and uh he was also really good i mean he
was just i mean you know that kind of
gets lost
sometimes in the discussion he just was
really really good at what he did and
it's not you know it's not
it's not like a sport like football or
baseball or basketball where it's about
the competition you know you're a track
star you measure yourself against a stop
watch from the time you're competing 16
you can telegraphically compete
against everyone in the world you just
need somebody holding a stopwatch at the
other end and the numbers didn't lie
he knew how good he was and he knew that
barring some kind of
significant injury there was no reason
that anybody should have been able to
defeat him maybe food poisoning that was
really the his biggest fear
more than any of the competition it's
fascinating reading some of the uh some
of the newspaper accounts of of the
games themselves and of uh
of the events themselves thomas wolfe is
one of the more skeptical observers and
you point out writing in your book
triumph the untold story of jesse owens
and hitler's olympics although the
germans had packed away their uniforms
into closets and their anti-semitic
posters into warehouses they could not
hide what was in their hearts and the
thought of it made wolf shiver
did so many western journalists miss
what wolf saw or did they just choose
not to acknowledge the the masquerading
nazi agenda you know it
it's it's interesting because
you know as you point out before this is
1936 this isn't 1938. the nuremberg laws
stripping jews of their most basic
rights have been enacted the previous
fall
but
uh there was hope even among germany's
jews that things were going to get
better not worse that that hitler
basically reached his nadir with the
nuremberg laws and from there things
would stabilize
and certainly this is the delusion that
not only um the jews were suffering from
but the western democracies as well in
march 1936 he marches into the rhineland
he violates the terms of the treaties of
lucarno and versailles and nobody does
anything about it and he's emboldened by
that um
but
this is two years before
the annexation of austria this is two
years before he pressures uh the hand
over the sudetenland in czechoslovakia
this is two years before crystal knocked
uh and he's trying to present a
different face
you know
the jews aren't gonna have their full
rights but
they weren't murdering people in the
street
and yet the people who had been there
uh covering
the regime in its first three years
could see what was happening uh william
l shirer saw it very clearly in his
diaries from the time
the british diplomat in charge in berlin
said you guys are crazy you shouldn't
set we shouldn't be going to these games
the american
envoy in berlin george messersmith
communicated the same things to the
state department and yet there were a
lot of people smart people who who
who chose to think that things had
gotten as bad as they were going to get
i want to take another question from
from our theater audience please go
ahead in the olympics
owens had already won the 100 220 in the
broad jump before
these
before the uh the relay
could you explain a little bit
about the decision to drop
two jewish guys who whose times were
fast enough so that the foursome would
have won that to drop them and
put uh owens
and another fellow uh
as their subs it's it's a complicated
story and uh it's a story that i think
has been mistold for a long time
um and if
you want me to get into it in detail um
jesse has won three gold medals in the
three individual events in which he's
competed everybody expects his olympics
are over they think he's done the plan
had always been for him to compete in
the 200 yard 200 meter 100 meter
dashes and the broad jump
and then to let everybody else get their
chance in the four by 100 meter relay
but after he wins his gold medal his
third gold medal 200 meters
he starts campaigning
to be on the relay team and that's
something that you know hasn't
been written about in a long time quite
frankly probably 70 years and i was
surprised when i read the newspaper
stories and the archival research i did
it was right there and yet everything
nothing i had ever read about owens had
pointed this out
he wanted to run
he wanted a fourth gold medal
um the plan for had been for him not to
run
ultimately the
two chief us track coaches lawson
robertson and dean cromwell
dropped the only two jews on the track
team sam stoller and marty glickman on
the day of the relay
uh
they are
uh replaced by owens
and you could ar you could argue either
ralph metcalf or floyd draper at the end
of the day you end up with ralph metcalf
and jesse owens who are both black and
floyd draper and frank wyckoff who are
both usc trojans dean cromwell was the
coach at usc
marty glickman who would go on to become
a legendary broadcaster and one of the
finest gentlemen in the industry
um
always asserted that it was
anti-semitism
uh that brundage
conspiring with robertson and cromwell
had the jews removed from the team so as
not to embarrass their german hosts by
putting two jews on the gold medal
platform because it was clear the
americans were going to win the gold
medal uh regardless of which four of the
six they chose to run
i i don't think it's quite that simple
sam stoller the other jew removed from
the team
uh felt differently for his part he
thought it was simply
uh dean cromwell looking out for the
guys who ran for him at usc rather than
anti-semitism
frank wyckoff one of those guys thought
it was anti-semitism jesse owens didn't
think it was anti-semitism
you know it's rashimon i mean there are
a million different ways to look at it
and
uh i personally think it's a combination
of those factors certainly lawson
robertson and dean cromwell would go on
to prove that they were no
fans of
jewish athletes
but clearly dean cromwell was also a fan
of having two more of his runners win
two easy gold medals in the four by 100
meter spring
robertson justified his decision by
saying that he had heard reports that
the germans had been hiding their best
runners to surprise the americans in the
400 meter relay which is demonstrably
absurd you can't hide world-class
runners they had gotten
uh their posteriors kicked in the
individual races
um
and
and he said well it's my job to put the
best four guys i can out there on the
track especially because i'm hearing the
germans you know have hidden these guys
well that doesn't make any sense either
on its face because in the other relay
the four by 400 meter relay
he picks
the four guys with the trials finished
third
through sixth
and the guys who finished first second
uh archie williams and jimmy lavalle are
not on that relay they both happen to be
black
they had won already the gold and the
bronze medals in the 400 meter
individual race a brit had won the
silver medal and a brit had come in
fourth so you've got americans finishing
one three and brits finishing 2-4
yet neither of those guys runs in the
relay and the u.s loses by a full two
seconds to great britain
so that's a long way of getting around
to saying that he wasn't being
consistent logically uh but the big
controversies about what happens in that
meeting where he announces that that it
that stoller and glickman are off
glickman always said that jesse stood up
and said let marty and sam run
owen said i never heard him i couldn't
find any record of him having said that
uh having claimed to have said that i
found an instance where he said that he
got up and said let sam run which makes
more sense because if he says let marty
and sam run he's volunteering somebody
else's position as well
uh frank
ralph metcalfe would become jesse's best
friend
uh and a four-term u.s representative
from chicago not that that's any
indication of his uh propensity for
honesty um
always said that jesse didn't say a word
i tend to believe that jesse after
having
uh campaigned all week to be on the
relay didn't say a word we only have
about 10 minutes left and sorry i want
to go to two other two other events you
were um
the the relay was owen's fourth gold
medal is unprecedented fourth gold medal
and one that that many thought he would
never vie for but the story that comes
after his first gold medal in the 100
meters and the idea of of the hitler the
uh the snub from from adolf hitler
where is the fact and where is the
fiction in this story this is another
hard one for me to be succinct on but
i'll try i promise uh uh
this is if there's one thing that most
people
know or think they know about the 1936
olympics it's that adolf hitler snubbed
jesse owens well it's it's uh
it's not true um
it is true that hitler did not recognize
him did not go out of his way to
congratulate him did not find a way to
acknowledge his achievement uh but the
stub story as jesse owens said at the
time
uh was false
what happened was this on the first day
of the competition
two germans win gold medals hitler takes
him up to his box he
you know he congratulates them very
publicly he goes out of his way to count
out of them and then three fins finish
one two three as was the custom in track
back then in the 10 000 meters the fins
won everything and these guys look more
aryan they're more blonde than the
germans themselves um and he
congratulates them as well very publicly
now the other competition that's going
on that day is the high jump and it's
clearly
uh the gold medal is clearly going to go
to an african-american named cornelius
johnson
the competition runs long though not
because because there is a a jump off
for the silver and bronze medals
between two americans delos thurber
who's white and david albritton jesse
owens old friend
who's black
so hitler leaves before the competition
is decided it started to rain he leaves
now there's an uproar he intentionally
left so that he wouldn't have to
congratulate a black american who was
clearly going to win the gold medal if
anybody had a right to feel snubbed it
was cornelius johnson the germans for
their part imagine this this is a time
when hitler wants to please as many
people as possible says no no no offense
intended i was just scheduled to leave
might be true
i don't think that he was looking
forward to shaking cornelius johnson's
hand
uh but it might be true that he was
simply adhering to his schedule
in any event the head of the
international olympic committee is so
upset about this controversy that he
reminds hitler that he's forbidden from
congratulating anyone unless he chooses
to congratulate everyone
hitler again eager to please at this
point
uh exceeds to count on reid to bailly
towards demand and agrees not to
congratulate anyone by the time jesse
owens wins his first gold medal the next
day in 100 meters
he is honoring his pledge he is not
congratulating anyone
including jesse owens
still the stub story becomes huge the
papers black and white in the u.s make
it banner headline 48-point type across
the top of the page
hitler snubs jesse jesse does everything
he can to tell people no i think he
waved at me once
i swear he waved to me some of the
writers think that hitler did kind of
acknowledge them most of them don't the
only black reporters covering the
olympics american black reporters i
should say for the pittsburgh courier
they report a whole story
jesse honored by adolf hitler
it's it's right there and it's the
opposite and jesse went on for a long
time telling people he wasn't snub but
that wasn't the story people wanted and
did jesse owens later say that the real
snub came from president roosevelt
he did i mean this is another
interesting facet of the story i mean
how much uh you know that i was unaware
of for instance 1936 is really the
tipping point uh for african americans
in this country between allegiance to
the party of lincoln the republican
party now the party of franklin
roosevelt jesse owens like joe lewis is
behind the curve like joe lewis he
campaigns for alf landon against
franklin roosevelt in 1936
and in fact uh
probably accepts ten thousand dollars to
do so
and it several stops on his stump tour
he says it wasn't hitler who snubbed me
it was franklin roosevelt
was there ever a more
unanticipated friendship to come out of
modern athletics than that between jesse
owens and and lutzlong now this is this
is really um
you know i mean it sounds corny um but
it really is you know you you've got
22 year old poor kid from alabama
grandson of slaves and you've got this
middle class highly educated um
blonde embodiment of the aryan ideal in
litzlong and lutzlong the story goes
helps jesse qualify for the finals and
long jump when he fouls in his first two
attempts he comes up to him in a spirit
of true sportsmanship
gives him some advice owens takes it
owens then goes on to beat long in the
final
spectacular duel between the two of them
the first person congratulate him is
lutzlong
grabs him by the arm parades around the
olympic infield arm in arm you know
this this blonde german and this you
know african-american in full view of
hitler
they strike up i think what becomes a
very genuine friendship back at the
olympic village and if there's one great
tale of sportsmanship and camaraderie
and everything the olympics are
supposed to embody it is i think the
friendship between lutz long and jesse
owens and when you uh read from the
prologue in the book you had mentioned
it was 1955 and jesse owens was finally
getting his due why was that so so late
in coming why did it take so long for
jesse owens to realize the benefits of
his success in 1936 well i think there
are a few factors at play first of all
he gets back in 1936 and um
the laurels
you know he he is celebrated there's no
doubt about that and people want to
write stories about him and want to hold
him up as an example of american
strength in the face of german
aggression but they don't want to give
him a job
and um
and he finds it very hard to find his
way financially he is still very much
you know i hate to use the term
constantly but a second class citizen
while his teammates who have won less
and are less celebrated you know go to
hollywood and make movies make money in
bands etc glenn morris becomes tarzan
and it's also though a factor of simply
nostalgia i think general rule in sports
as in in sports is you need 20 years to
kind of become an icon
you know the the there's the immediate
afterglow and everybody loves you and
then people kind of forget and then
world war ii came and and obviously
people stopped thinking about the
olympics for a while but by the 50s as i
indicated in the prologue he becomes a
very convenient
uh
goodwill ambassador for the u.s and for
its way of life uh to hold up his look
you know the the soviet system is going
around the world saying look how they
treat their blacks look how they treat
their minorities we can do better for
you and he goes around the world to tell
people
you can do well here when we look at and
i was i was really trying to focus on
the timeline
how much time passed from jesse owens
fourth gold medal in the relay to the
time that brundage had stripped him of
his amateur status one week one week
exactly and this is jesse owens being
forced as an unpaid participant to take
part in an exhibition tour that the aau
is using to fund the games and jesse
owens mind you with no endorsement
contract
is
literally dependent on on passengers
next to them in a plane to eat no i mean
it's you know it's it's it's unspeakable
today what they did i mean he wins the 4
by 100 meter relay they say get on a
train right now
uh you got to go to the airport we're
sending you to cologne uh he competes
and meets in cologne he competes in a
meet in czechoslovakia he competes in a
meet in germany he competes in a meet in
england all of this while the olympics
are still going on
uh to put money in the aau's and the
aoc's coffers uh finally there's another
leg on the trip to stockholm and all the
time remember jesse's won four gold
medals he's gained telegrams coming to
new york i'll give you twenty five
thousand dollars to appear with
eddie canner with bojangles and he's
sitting on these offers he thinks
they're gonna dry up and finally he says
they don't give him a dime
not even a sandwich as you said and
finally he refuses to go on the last
trip to stockholm
you've been listening to meet the author
on your npr station 887 fm wbfo our
guest jeremy schapp selection for this
month jeremy's new book triumph the
untold story of jesse owens and hitler's
olympics
coming up on meet the author march 19th
7 o'clock at musical fair theater
carolyn smarts frost is here an
underground railroad story titled i've
got a home in glory land michael wallace
on april 24th also at musical fair that
selection billy the kid the endless ride
and thursday may third a seven o'clock
start at the roycroft inn in east aurora
our guest fred pierce will be discussing
his book with speed and violence why
scientists fear tipping points in
climate change i'd like to thank the
vice president of student affairs at the
university at buffalo for all of his
help dennis black wbfo's general manager
is carol petro dave benders joan wilson
mike mckay and kara sweet at the station
as well our sound engineer jim bakrady
with help tonight from jarrell billings
doug blakely is our technical director
joe jorano and doug morgano provided our
pre-show music johnny garcia thanks for
your help at the student union theater
at the university at buffalo north
campus production assistants as well
from debbie sims and kyle kryzak thanks
to john welch at talking leaves books
and our sponsors this evening
buffalorising.com and the university at
buffalo division of student affairs at
channel 7 john deschillo leadsenzia
linda pellegrino and lorraine o'donnell
and thanks to our members at wbfo as
well whose financial support makes all
of our programming on the radio station
possible meet the author is produced by
kelly beaucoc natalie i'm bert gambini
jeremy schapp thank you very much for
coming to buffalo and visiting with us
at the university at buffalo thank you
bernie thank all of you
jeremy schapp is author of cinderella
man james braddock max bear and the
greatest upset in boxing history
his latest is triumph the untold story
of jesse owens and hitler's olympics
an anchor for espn learn more about
jeremy shap
[Applause]
more about american sports next with nba
hall of famer kareem abdul-jabbar nfl
hall of famer michael irvin and others
talking about sports and race the panel
was hosted by the u.s conference of
mayors it's just over an hour
all right thanks matthew
all right mayors i i hope you guys are
situated and seated uh we're gonna have
a really dynamic panel here
i know a lot of you had a good time over
the weekend and we're looking forward to
it uh you stayed on monday
for one we had business to conduct and
then two it was this real this really
impressive panel so let me give a little
background as i kind of bring up
each of our panelists and before we do
that i'll have mayor ballard come up
with in a moment
from jackie robinson integrating
baseball
to tommy smith and john carlos saluting
human rights in the 1968 olympics medal
ceremony
sports have time and time again
played a pivotal role in advancing civil
rights
nba commissioner adam silvers
swift indecisive response to l.a
clippers owner donald sterling's racial
charge comments
makes clear that in today's society
institutionalist
institutionalized racism
is not welcome
in light of both events and the
long-standing battle against
discrimination and institutional racism
in professional sports
we are taking the necessary action today
to discuss the social and political
implications of racism in sports
through this interactive conversation
panelists will tackle questions that can
tell us why racism still pervades our
sports as well as our society
more importantly we are convening today
to learn and to discuss how sports
should serve our communities and how we
together can become agents of change in
our cities with our sports teams
before we move on to our panel i would
like to introduce a leader in addressing
the intersection between sports and
cities
indianapolis mayor greg ballard is chair
of our mayor
professional sports alliance
the mission of this alliance is to share
among mayors
information resources and support on
issues related to professional sports
and to work effectively with leagues
players and owners skip a round of
applause for mayor ballard
good morning
mr president distinguished guests
sports
bring people together
they bring communities together
certainly during a deep playoff run
when athletes do good work in the
community
sports bring nations together
how many of us gasped
at portugal's last second goal last
night
but sports can also divide us
and there could be a meanness
and ugliness
as is the case in this clippers episode
i was proud
that the mayor's professional sports
alliance stood with our president
kevin johnson as he worked with the
players and the alumni
as they address this situation
and i do applaud the nba for taking
swift and decisive action
but ultimately sports organizations
are part of who we are
they represent us as a community
and despite the elite athleticism that
we all witness
we really want them
to embody
our character
and our compassion
as a community
and that includes the respect
for all
of our citizens
to me diversity has always been about
respect
and respect was lacking
in the clippers organization
sports mirror our society
and so far that inclusion
that respect
has come
at such a great price
such as the life
of jackie robinson
it is all of our responsibility
to continue the march
i look forward to the panel thank you so
much
[Applause]
thanks mayor ballard
all right i'm going to introduce the
panelists
and then we're going to have a
serious conversation
so our first panelist
that i'd like to bring out to give a
mural perspective on this important
issue
is our very own michael nutter as we
know philadelphia has a reputation
of being a passionate sports town
we can hear booze all over the country
for the eagles and the phillies and the
sixers and the clippers if you're not
from philadelphia especially in
sacramento
it has a long history of sports in
philadelphia as it has spurred on
serious conversation about race
former phillies manager ben chapman was
one of the loudest voices opposing
jackie robins jackie robinson's
integration to baseball let's give a
round of applause for our very own past
president michael nutter
all right secondly
i'd like to bring it don't have a seat
mike again
secondly i'd like to bring out
a person who was originally scheduled to
moderate it
and i thought he would probably give
more and better perspective sitting on a
panel
so we switched places
i didn't know i was going to lose my
voice
so roland martin an influential reporter
commentator
long career at bet
cnn the defender in chicago most
recently tv one has his own program
called news one now he's from houston he
was born in houston in texas went to
texas a m a journalist
got his master's degree in christian
communications has written several books
let's give a round of applause for
roland martinez
go ahead row you can all right
all right since we're in dallas
mayor rawlings this is for you
i get a chance to introduce a dallas
cowboy legend
and this is a surprise guest for us we
didn't put him on the schedule
intentionally so mayor rollins would be
surprised this man led the dallas
cowboys to not one
or two
but three super bowl championships
he's one of 17 children
from fort lauderdale
went to the university of miami
won a championship there
one of the greatest wide receivers to
ever play the game let's give a round of
applause for michael irving
[Applause]
let me say hello
i think most of you know that michael is
also now a personality and commentates
uh on football on a regular basis
and uh he's got that personality that's
just magnetic and it's awesome to have
him here i don't know if you got it if
you ever got a chance to see his
acceptance speech in the hall of fame
and i know most of you have it was one
of the most amazing acceptance speeches
of all time so one more round of
applause for the playmaker
[Applause]
all right
this is the biggest introduction i'm
ever going to make
i mean is this just not exciting about
who's about to come out
y'all should clap for him and say his
name
just let him know we love him before i
even say his name
all right just listen to this i didn't
want to go long but just listen to this
for a minute
six-time
nba championship
this man won six of them
six time most valuable player
19-time
nba all-star
hall of fame inductee
played with the bucks in milwaukee gave
a little love there won a championship
then went out west to la and won five
more
from new york
went to ucla
played under john wooden
won three championships in college
if you add those two up that's like nine
the man as a freshman
was not allowed to play varsity sports
or he would have had a 10th
in college he was so effective they
literally changed the rule
because he was there this is like a a
rule changer in a real way
he's a legend
he also
a new york times best-selling author
have written books on history and civil
rights including black profiles and
courage
what color is in my world
a host of books a documentary has been
written about and made about one of his
books harlem ren's
two-time
naacp image award winner
get on your feet and give a round of
applause for the one and only the
greatest player to ever play the game
kareem abdul jabar
i feel like we can all go home
i feel like we've been to church and we
ain't even said a word yet
look at it look at kareem just for a sec
look at
dignified and distinguished
and what makes him so amazing not only
arguably the best player to ever play
the game but it wasn't just what he did
on the court
it's what he did off the court and to me
for him to be here today with these
panelists is amazing and just so you
know this is often something people
don't know about kareem abdul-jabbar
he's not an out front person
behind the scenes last night he took a
half a dozen mares out to dinner so can
you give him a round of applause for
treating our mares to dinner last night
as well
all right you all ready
okay we're gonna get it going we're
gonna have this panel discussion
i'm going to stand up here because i'm
losing my voice a little bit so
i want to first throw the first question
out to mayor nutter
mayor
what was your gut reaction
when you heard the donald sterling tape
i have to tell you i was uh i was really
stunned i mean i at first
my folks told me about it and i said
well i mean is this true i mean does
somebody really say this i mean you know
you have all these
tapes and youtube and all that and
certainly the elected officials know
about you know all that stuff then i
said well maybe it was maybe his doctor
uh you know how
how did somebody say all of that
so
i watched it
and
and i knew it was like nine or ten
minutes or so i said well i'm probably
not going to watch this whole thing i
just want to see and i mean it's the
epitome of like an accident on the i
mean it was
it was just fascinating i mean in every
piece just it just went on and on and on
and at the end i mean i was just like
discuss it i mean maybe you want to dog
magic you want to you know talk about
people call folks out their name and all
this other kind of stuff like you're
like an owner of a teen you're just like
an adult you're supposed to be
responsible
and i
so i mean you know i
i had some other thoughts but you know
this is a family program so i mean
it was insane but i mean it's obviously
it's been found to be
you know true legit and um you know i
mean we know the end of the story and we
have to give
our president uh certainly
huge recognition for the role that he
played and the nba and and and the
commissioner uh certainly handled it
properly but it was a stunning moment i
think in america awesome so uh
kareem question for you same question
you know you wrote a very impressive
time magazine piece which was awesome
so what was your first reaction
and they're probably going to be
surprised with your comment but go ahead
cream
my first reaction was surprise because i
had worked for mr sterling i coached the
clippers
in the year 2000
he invited me to his daughter's wedding
i had no
idea
exactly what was going on but i also uh
because of my association i i know elgin
baylor i know what he was complaining
about so i i was confused
not knowing exactly
which set of facts
mr sterling stood behind and then when
his words came out it was it was so
obvious and and shocking
and uh just disgusting
uh all those things wrapped in one but
the surprise of it to find that type of
sentiment in someone who relies on uh
black americans
for so much of his success and and
public profile it was amazing i i just
couldn't believe it that someone could
could have that much bigotry inside and
think that it was okay
michael
what was your
gut reaction when you first heard it
you know i i was i thought i was hurt
you know hurt for certainly the players
on on the court
um and and for the fans because
let's be real here the clippers but
they've been waiting a long time for
this
where they are right now they've been
waiting a long time and there have been
a lot of fans a lot of loyal
fans and and have doc rivers they have
chris paul
guys that really are such outstanding
african-americans that represent the
best we have to offer
and then to
point out and attack one of the best we
have to offer in magic johnson i i was i
was hurt i was hurt for all of those
other people i won't say that i was
totally shocked
because i i truly believe and i
understand we still have the remnants
of some of these still left
so i'm not shocked but i was hurtful and
we have heard
some things
prior to this about donald sterling and
the bible says out abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks and and as we go
on and on and he kept going on and on i
think we heard more of his heart i was
shocked and hurt for all of those people
uh roland i'm going to ask you the same
question and for everybody out there
watching him do what he did he's doing
right there he does not have add
well he may have that too but he he's
just a
a twitter mania this man tweets like
nobody's business so i want you to know
that he's he's paying attention roland i
got him some new followers
go ahead um my reaction was and
see folks were all surprised by it and i
think what people more surprised about
was the fact that he
said it
in to the degree that he did
but the reason i was
some way pleased with it because
we are living in absolute denial
because we have too many people are
walking around going oh my god we have a
black president this is a post-racial
america
you actually had eric bowling on the fox
news who said all this stuff about
racism i don't even see it does it even
exist
all you all you have to do is go to the
eeoc website and you will see case after
case after case after case uh of
examples after president obama was
elected
and so what happens is we all of a
sudden act as if well you know things
are changing you see black ceos you see
black mayors governors and the president
so somehow these things have been wiped
out when dr king said in chaos or
community where do we go from here it's
what do we do about what is in
somebody's heart
and for him to be a team owner it's no
shock uh just look you got a city
councilwoman in lamar texas
who was recorded saying
we need to get those blacks off the
school board
and she refuses to apologize she is
unapologetic saying i said it and we
need to get those blacks off the school
board
and so it causes people to go wait a
minute we have to confront the reality
of race in america who's here from akron
ohio and with akron ohio mayor's over
here the akron beacon journal wanted
people's surprise
several years ago for a whole series on
race and ushering a city-wide
conversation and part of this is because
what we love to do in america we love to
not have
that brutally honest discussion we want
to have the nice sweet we all get along
conversations without realizing there
are people in power who own businesses
who are elected officials
who might be in charge of yes having
black folks who work for them but have a
hardcore view on the issue of race and
so it caused a lot of people to force
themselves to say wait a minute we might
want to examine ourselves and it forced
the nba to have to answer some questions
as to when you had all of these examples
of this owner and the issue of race over
the years you were silent about it and
said nothing including that major
housing lawsuit and he had to pay the
money out and the league did nothing
so kareem let me come back to you
and i think most of you know that i mean
cream
went to college in the 60s
when civil rights
were at the top of his game
and you played professional sports
60s and 70s
tell us
are we at the end of an era or help us
connect with what you were going through
then and where you think we are today
well i think what has happened is
when we had the fact that
we had the legal means to combat racism
institutionalized racism
a lot of black americans said okay it's
now now we have the tools to achieve
something but it has taken us decades to
achieve those things that we had the
tools to work on
and when it comes to working on what's
in people's hearts
and their minds with regard to the
inferiority of people who do not look
like them we have a very long way to go
even though we have these tools we have
a long way to go because a lot of people
do not understand their own bigotry it's
so
endemic to
the human experience
that
too many people don't get it when
they are
very intensely affected by racism and do
racist acts they're not even
aware of it so we still have a very long
way to go mayor johnson position this
properly
position this properly
emmett teal is killed august 28 1955 the
montgomery bus boycott begins december
1st 1955. you go to the civ you go to
the city ends in 1960 the students of
north carolina and t you go to the march
on washington for jobs and freedom
august 28 1963 civil rights act voting
rights act fair housing act nixon gets
elected in 68 southern strategy but also
affirmative action comes in so in a
period of 13 years the country was
transformed so use 1968 as the marker of
so-called
full freedom for african americans
that's 46 years
right now 45 and a half years
1968. so you say dr king is killed april
4th 1968 and you say affirmative action
arthur fletcher with nixon so this is
u-68 as the marker okay so-called full
freedom for black folks in 68.
this is a 46-year period i'm 45
will be 46 in november
so we walk around as if oh my god things
have changed and also we have amazing
freedom but in the history of the
country african-americans of u-68 which
we know is a false year anyway because
you had the whole issue in boston and
other cities became a desegregation and
busing
46 years so-called freedom
so when you expanded beyond donald
sterling's comments about race you
expanded the issue of housing and
economics and uh inclusion you go beyond
that you will see that yes we've come a
long way but we're only talking about
46 years of so-called full freedom and
so if you think that we somehow have
gotten over the issue of race
we have to be delusional because it
didn't happen in 46 years in the same
way in south africa where we celebrated
nelson mandela's passing but you still
have in that country where africa where
south africans who are black still don't
have access to power economically and
politically they might be president of
the countries but they don't control
capital
so michael and i'm going to ask you both
the same question in some respect i
think most you remember
there was a philadelphia eagles football
player who got video recorded saying the
n-word
and so what was your thought
when you first heard that and then
michael you're the mayor of the city
where it happened well it's a couple of
things that i'm going to hold on to what
you talked about 60 years and us being
45 years past that date and i'm going to
come back to that but i'll address the
riley cooper situation and and how i
addressed it because that's my job every
sunday and thursday to talk about the
things that goes on the things that go
on in sports um
you know riley cooper i've watched and
riley's been playing football for a lot
of years
one of the things i talked about
when this issue came up i was just
coming from a basketball camp with my
son in in in las vegas
and as we walked by the pool they had
music blasting saying the n word
50 different ways to sunday
and everybody was rocking and having a
great time and and riley cooper steps in
the club and he steps out in an angering
situation
drops inward and here we go um
of course saying everything about riley
cooper i i thought first of all and i
said it then and i'll say it now first
of all we all have to take
responsibilities as african americans
for injecting the word out there and
making it okay now riley cooper said it
in a moment of heat
in a moment of heat the words in my is
right words already put in your spirit
through all the songs you're listening
to in a moment of heat you let the word
go do i count him as a racist oh you and
i said i don't think so this man had
been around people for all of his life
we would have received that now rich
incarnito situation is a little bit
different in miami
because i thought that's exactly what
the word was used and how it was used
back in the day richie incognito used
the word as a systematic way to break
down another man
now that is what i call racism a
systematic way of breaking down the
other man now that's not tolerable
i just want y'all to know when they say
athletes are not smart look at the these
two up here
look i'm sitting next to the dictionary
kareem abdul-jabbar is like a dictionary
this man know every single meaning of
every word
and for him to be able to break down the
issues
this is what just drives me crazy as a
former athlete because people don't give
athletes enough credit for what they do
and their perspectives and i think these
are just great examples so michael he
knows more words than don king yeah he
does
he absolutely test him put him on the
spot he was on a this is a true honest
got true we was on a uh cream and i were
on a uh
a street car in san francisco mary lee
we were getting some award and we're
riding around i'm just looking at him
the whole time he's like can you quit
looking i was like screaming
so we
riding around so then i said
i said
tell me something about the great walls
of china i was just trying to be funny
this man said did you know
the rock
was a quarry built for i was like who
knows about the great wallet
that's a true story
so so mayor nutter same topic because
you had to deal with it head-on yeah i
did and uh the
my reaction was
swift
aggressive
and negative
and i saw that tape
and
we put out a we put out a statement
that
said that he
he needed to clean it up he needed to
fix it and i think quite honestly
as i saw it
i was left with the impression that it
wasn't the first time
in his life
that he had used that word
and so that calls into question a whole
host of other
issues and
um
you know the team
tried to deal with it all of a sudden he
you know he suddenly had to go away
we it was never really clear where what
but i mean i think they're just trying
to get him out of
out of town out of the situation um you
know philly is not a um
we're seasoned in the back michael
irving because he always loved playing
in philadelphia
and
[Laughter]
so our fans are passionate
it's not an overreaction kind of town
but there was a lot of reaction to that
uh
uh it's a player
they were home they weren't on the field
it was a off you know but i mean it was
it was a very very negative reaction to
it and you know i have some thoughts
about you know what how it was handled
and whether it was completely handled uh
properly but you know
season started
there wasn't much stuff he went on to
have a
pretty good season and i'm not going to
sit here and say that all is forgotten
so i think obviously you asked the
question people remember
he's trying to get past it
but
you know
when i see him on tv or if i'm at the
game
i hear his name
i immediately remember that so he's got
to deal with that but mayor we will feel
a false reality
and a false discussion about race here's
what it has evolved into
riley cooper racist
not a racist right right right you watch
these cable news shows and it was this
exact same thing uh with a donald
sterling conversation and many other it
becomes racist not a racist right as if
there is nothing in between those two
right so what happens is folks begin to
say no you are a racist and so you have
all the people commenting on that end
and the people who are defending said
well no i've known him i've lived with
them we've hung out he's not a racist
as if there is nothing that's in between
that deals with how we've grown up it
deals with our perceptions it deals with
look i make this example against nothing
against athletes but there's nothing
that pisses me off more than going
around the country and i'm rocking my
texas a m gear and somebody says
when you play ball there
hell i didn't play ball
now the first question is not
did you graduate
or what's your major in
i was playing golf one day the dude said
so how was it playing of jackie cheryl i
think off my brother was also texas a m
graduate and i just written a column two
weeks earlier for the foot warsaw
telegram the headline was no i'm not a
football player
and he
so he's on that side of the fairway i'm
in the middle of the fair with my
brother's on this side he asked the
question and i got a five run in my hand
i'm just twirling that sucker just
looking there that pen going and my
brother just go oh my god please don't
answer please don't answer so i didn't
respond we finally got to finish that
whole lot go to the t he goes i don't
know why ask that question yes you do
so what happens is we have perceptions
and we have beliefs and
a lot of them are based on race if i see
a six five white guy i automatically
don't assume he play basketball
i just i just don't
so what happens is when we talk about
race
we have to acknowledge if there's
something that's in between not a racist
you're a racist that plays into this uh
and then we simply don't like to have
that because now it brings into question
how our mothers and fathers raised us
how our friends around us and so i often
ask people when you talk about the issue
of race i moderated this thing in
wilmington delaware at the king day and
then all these these black and white
hispanic and asian students and they
said all we get long is great and i was
sitting there going this is a bunch of
bs right here so i said let me ask y'all
a question
who do you eat lunch with
and they went
what do you mean i said who do you eat
lunch with
and when i ask that question
all of a sudden
the butt dancing but i use this on tv
time when you when you kicking somebody
behind to get uncomfortable they start
getting in the chair start doing this
here
i call that butt dancing
they start by dancing the whole room and
i said
you can't tell me y'all get along and
you live in this wonderful race neutral
world because who you choose to go to
lunch with defines
your view
i then to the parents and i said okay
who eats at your house for dinner
room got real uncomfortable
what happens is school
work or what i call involuntary
situations you don't control really who
gets hired
but who you eat with and go to lunch
with is a voluntary situation and
oftentimes we eat the people who we are
like
as opposed to folks a lot of times based
upon race when i put that out there the
whole conversation changed because they
realized that they had self-segregated
but they thought they were all
multiracials all wonderful and they
never dawned on them if they were
self-segregating but they thought
because they sat in the same classroom
they were living in this multi-racial
world that's in terms of again if you
take donald sterling and these other
issues how do you begin to examine the
issue of race in a whole different way
let me ask this right quick because you
know we have to be careful and you said
there's a schism
it's it's not so black and white but if
a guy comes up to you and asks
because you and you have one if i have
on the you t-shirt uh and he says man
what year you play ball
does that mean he's racist
you see we have to be careful there too
well i don't make it racist right right
right but but there's a perception
though because if if he saw a dude my
size uh if he saw a white guy my size i
ain't asking that question
let's just be honest
what now see now you can't say you're
not saying anything about him you just
made an assessment but he will not ask
ain't gonna answer
you'll see what i'm saying
and honestly because we see and that
that's the strappings that we have to be
careful with i may ask when i see a 6'5
white guy i'm going to wonder today he
plays basketball if not he's wasting
some nice height i wish he could have
given it to my nephew you see what i
mean so so those things and maybe that
has something to do with time or the
people we've been around or the cultures
that we've come up with but you know i
and sports are huge let's think through
this sports are huge in this country i
mean
the money we spent on sports so when
someone sees you in an end maybe you
went to a m or sees me in a u-shirt and
you know we we can't just naturally
assume oh oh it must be something just
because i'm black i don't mean i play
sports you know i graduate all of those
things i'm just saying in order to
really grow and be edified we got to
watch it on both ways my bishop always
tells me put yourself in the next man's
shoes if you will that's what i'm saying
i didn't call them a racist what i'm
saying is there are there are
perceptions there are stereotypes that
we buy into
and when you see it over a period of
years and then and then when i when i
raise it somebody goes
whoa right i didn't realize that i
jumped to a car
with you because i and what we're
dealing with here though is the whole
idea of the word prejudice the word
prejudice means pre-judging so when you
come into a situation and you already
know
oh that's uh yeah you played for uh uh
abilene state right
hey no i i i'm a doctor
wow
that
that's that's that's what we're talking
about judging and assessing are saying
in the same area but two different
things so i can pre-judge someone that
means i made up my mind who he is
assessing someone is mean i'm trying to
read and figure out where he is so when
asking a question
about uh man what position you play i
may be in the accessing not already
preaching that wasn't a question you
judge as opposed to saying man who or
where are you no no no no no no
no right here's so here's
a texas a m jersey right a shirt now so
i may be i'm thinking sports is that
what i'm saying no but here's the deal
though it's 500 000 former aggies out
there all of them didn't play yeah and
he made everybody everybody may not wear
a jersey either right they're saying i'm
got some sports only maybe they're
trying to
can you sit between between these two
go ahead another and i think
i may be offended
but no one's ever asked me did i play
paul
you know what i'm saying exactly right
i'm talking about damn
i i
i can actually throw
i can tell you something worse than that
that that happens to me people come up
to me
and ask me if i'm wilt chamberlain and i
say
will chamberlain is dead man
what is that all about
maybe they have dating advice
so roland let me let me ask you this
question
i want to get away from sterling for
just one sec because
it might you said it best maybe you
should make the comment you talked about
how sports gives us an opportunity to
have these say that when you told me
absolutely what we were talking about is
you know donald sterling's uh
the michael sam's situation
when they happen in sports because
sports garner so much attention from the
world and it's right there on tv
i can't i can't i can't even believe
they pay me what they paid me to talk
about
yeah i mean i'm
i tell people all the time man i was
fortunate enough to make millions faking
people out with my hips now i make
millions talking about how to fake
people out with my lips it is incredible
this is an incredible world it's
not nice
i love it i love it
[Laughter]
but but but having that opportunity
because it's so visible
it's so live it's so real
we don't get that if it's happening in
our fortune 500 companies
you know we don't get those
opportunities to talk about those things
and what we do is we are edified through
those conversations and let's take the
michael sam
situation for a moment if we will
growing up for me
calling
michael sam and guys that had a sexual
orientation
opposite of mine
we didn't even know that so when we used
the word
yeah i don't even want to say it because
f word i got a job and you know i'm
firing me for saying it but whenever
they use the f word it wasn't about
sexual orientation it was about a sign
of weakness
so now as we have these conversations we
start dispelling all the myths and
edifying one another and and getting
better at it now hey that's why i said i
want i want the first guy that is gay to
come in the league i want to be a
linebacker so they can knock somebody
out it doesn't it doesn't matter so we
can squash all of the stereotypes to
move forward that's what's great about
it all that's what's great about it that
having conversation is what we need now
i hate that we focus on the one like the
sterlings and all of those guys but but
we do need to have these conversations
i want to build on on
michael irving's point about sports
and in a more serious way for a moment i
mean it does play out literally
on the biggest stage
people are watching it's broadcast
there's money there's all kinds of
things going on but we go back in
history
a couple names
jesse owens
it wasn't just about running
what was going on at that time
right
at war near war
world issues
at the olympics
this was literally the united states of
america against germany
right
now being defined on a track
america's strength
1968 olympics
john carlos
decides to stand on the podium
with a black glove on his hand
puts his fist up in the 1960s as a sign
to the world
of what was on his mind
life changed
i mean
never really anything
for john carlos
our friend here
comes into the
nba
lou alcindor
changes his name
got right to change your name
huge controversy
in sports
cassius clay
muhammad ali
and then the whole issue and this is all
during certainly during my time in my
childhood i know exactly where i was
in march of 1971 listening on the radio
as people were trying you were either
a joe frazier fan
and that has that had one set of
perspectives
or you were muhammad ali
that had a different set of perspectives
for blacks and whites
and they were both in each
of those fighters camps
trying to define you know are you
radical or are you you know in a more
establishment
kind of mode and so i mean that's what's
been going on
i mean not all of that during my time
but certainly from the 60s on up
how
race
and other issues have played out on a
larger scale in the united states of
america and around the world
shaping attitudes and perspectives
on who we are and what we're about and a
lot of that continues uh certainly today
even
there's a danger though
has that not changed
i'm asking a question because
respectfully uh maybe you guys are just
some of you guys a few years older than
me here in this sense now that was that
was talking
that was nice okay he was a little
younger
yeah but but
that fight was about
saying that you know
we were inferior and and it was
sports said see we're not inferior
alley
well
and jesse owens and all and all of those
things it's about now now through sports
we show that we're not inferior is that
still the same fight we're having today
yes
yes but here's what jumped out at me
36 was positioned as america
versus nazi germany
but jesse owens when he came back could
not eat in restaurants in his own
country
and so to bring it present day
we will
praise
our athletes
as our warriors on the field
let's have a conversation about
education reform and are they actually
being taught in the very school that's
praising them for winning on friday
night
and so all of a sudden when we begin
to force the conversation
sports allows us because it is a
unifying matter if you will uh sports
and comedy really probably sports comedy
and music
are the three areas where literally uh
we come together regardless of
background depending on the price of the
ticket background ethnicity gender all
those different factors and we're sort
of all operating behind this one deal
uh but you notice all those are three
entertainment venues
so i think a lot of times we like to
okay cool we can get along it's great we
can do all this sort of stuff but then
when you go outside of that now you're
back in the real world
the problem that i have when we have
these conversations and as somebody who
spent six years on cnn uh i mean i have
been involved in media since i was 14
with the community went to a journalism
high school what happens is
we in media do the exact same thing
in the real world
okay let's hurry up in this conversation
uh because we can move on everything
let's go move back move on to what we're
talking about beforehand
let's hurry up and get off this stuff
dealing with michael sam and dealing
with race and dealing with agenda so we
can get back to playing games
because we like to play games versus
dealing with the hard stuff
and so what i always try to do is say
wait a minute no you have to keep that
conversation going because even if you
disagree
with
michael sam
disagree with riley cooper disagree with
incognito disagree with donald sterling
or even agree with him it's like the
whole mark cuban discussion folks were
upset i had no problem with what mark
cuban had to say because somebody said
hey
i got prejudices i'm biased and he puts
it on the table and the argument turned
into i remember watching uh seeing the
clip on cnn is cue and racist it was the
stupidest conversation in the world it
should have been
he puts it on the table so can we now
own up to our own prejudices and our own
biases and have that conversation
because part of the problem with a race
discussion in america if we really want
to be honest a lot of whites who really
want to talk about their personal
feelings but are afraid to actually save
for being called a racist and you have
to create the environment where people
can be honest about how they feel and
then begin to say okay so when he made
his comment about trayvon martin about
the hoodie
my first response wasn't you're racist
my first question would have been
mark
what has caused you to feel that way
what has brought you to that particular
viewpoint
and if somebody if the moderator had
asked that question you would have led
to why he felt that way which leads to
the next question what we have evolved
into is statement
denunciation
as opposed to statement
question
that has to happen so cream let me ask
you this
well
how much time we have
all right we're going to where to go my
flight leaves at 2 45. i'm just messing
with it just messing it up all right
wait a quick quick follow-up and then i
asked cream a question on it so
when the trayvon martin
incident happened
kobe bryant made a comment
in terms of the way the miami heat
players
addressed it they came out with the
hoodies on in solidarity
and you took
a little bit of exception to what kobe
had to say
give us your perspective on that really
well first um colby gave an interview to
the new yorker
i read the piece
and
the question that the
the the interviewer asked
really was
a a ridiculous question because he sort
of
mixed several things together he sort of
mixed what the miami heat did with kobe
getting criticism for not being more
evolved and active on various issues and
then kobe responded
the issue that i took with that is first
of all
what people
seem to forget
is that trayvon martin was killed on the
night of the nba all-star game
in in sanford in sanford florida the
game was the game was took place in
orlando he was going back home to watch
the game
it was another two months before it blew
up because frankly
national media ignored it
we drove it on social media
i remember tweeting dwyane wade who i
know
saying and i specifically said i am
stunned that players who live in orlando
and in miami are saying nothing about
this because he was he lived in miami
gardens
and so
duane i remember him tweeting roland
thanks thanks brother for pushing us and
keeping us
on these issues a day later
they made the statement
the problem i had with kobe was
he was missing critical facts as to what
actually happened and what took place
there
the heat players were not saying
george zimmerman was zimmerman was
guilty they were sending a signal
that we stand in solidarity and what
they also were saying with those hoodies
that even though we might be nba ballers
depending upon where we go
they may not recognize the face of
lebron or dwayne so we're just like
trayvon
so that was the issue that's why i took
issue with what he had to say and and i
went at kobe hard and look i make it
perfectly clear if i'm willing to
criticize the president and oprah kobe
i'ma swing at you too it don't even
matter okay my philosophy is if you do
good i'll talk about you if you mad i'll
talk about you then today i'm gonna talk
about you
he called my office and we had a we had
we had we had a we had a um a discussion
and he said
we know the issue that i stated was i
have a problem with people
jump to jump to someone's side because
of race
and i said kobe let me remind you
because of the history of black men
being accused of rape in america and
some black folks who jumped to your side
when you got accused of rape
[Applause]
so
in that conversation and it was
interesting i mean i was flying
somewhere and he hit me and i see this
number luckily i answered he said hey i
hear you talking about me i went who the
hell is this he said it's kobe i said
okay so i stepped to the side with about
20 minute conversation but it led to a
discussion and what was great about it
was and i told him i said kobe when you
make that statement the issue
the interview it made it sound as if the
heat players
jumped to the conclusion because trayvon
was black and that's not what they were
saying and i said that's what i took
exception to but it led to a
conversation and i told him i said we
can discuss it offline or i say look you
want to discuss it on television on
radio because there needs to be a
broader discussion here because jim
brown criticized him for the same thing
that's what i'm saying when these things
happen
we either can respond or we can
communicate and literally break it down
to have a back and forth and that's why
i think there's so many of us are afraid
that's why media is so important so we
can't we shouldn't have the eight-minute
quick discussion uh racist or non-racist
it's okay what do you mean by that how
do we get to that okay but can we also
can we also hear again on the other side
because if i'm walking it with my little
girl
and i see somebody walking and it's 98
degrees out like it often is here in
texas
and you have on a hoodie
over your head and 98 degrees
they don't come much blacker than me but
i'm going to be a little worried i got
my little girl with me i don't know why
you hide in your face 90 degrees so
don't mean i'm racist but i'm worried
you know uh i might have an iron i i
thought what happened with mark cuban
the other day mark if i see somebody
walking towards me with all tattoos all
over his bear and he got those little
teardrops in his eyes i just saw on tv
that means you're a murderer then that
means with your dress you wanted to
scare me i'm telling you that worked i'm
going on the other side of the road hold
on hold on right there
you got these two drop murders see so
what we can say that's what i'm telling
you we we all as humans have to access
assess the things around us our own
health is involved the freezer right
there you just said i just saw it on tv
yes if i just right exactly so i'm
grabbing an assessment i'm grabbing an
assessment we're taking we're making
absolutes out of things no no no no no
no
but i'm glad you said that because you
actually you're proving my point what
happens is we are watching television
we are watching other movies or the news
and all of a sudden what we are being
fed is driving our perceptions of one
another which also goes back to the work
that you're involved in in terms of your
documentaries your movies and your books
and what i'm doing as well by saying
maybe part of the problem is we have an
unbalanced diet of what we have been fed
in america that is driving these racial
perceptions that's part of the issue so
michael are you good on that or not that
the problem is
down in the room i i understand that i
believe some of that is reality okay
korean so let me out let me ask you this
so we're wrapping up here cream i have a
two-part question the first one
in terms of
just simply what what role has sports
played
in in race relations just give us that
perspective
uh i think sports has the potential to
to be a great
uh
area where people can bridge to one
another and by that i mean
uh
we all right
los angeles lakers win the world
championship they have a street parade
downtown in front of city hall
the whole community was there
on the spanish language movie theater
saludos a lakers campiones mondeau
people from the korean community what i
tell you people speaking languages go
ahead
people from korean community
south central uh
l.a
uh west side
the valley
orange county they all came together it
was wonderful and then you look at the
opposite when things don't work like
that when we have the rodney king
incident
and la was tearing itself apart
there's still uh uh charcoal alleys in
uh different parts of la behind that so
sports can can bring us together uh
in terms of the big community as
individuals you go out there every day
you work in on the baseball field or in
on your weight room or on football field
with with people
who who aren't like you and you see that
they're hard-working
they have a sense of humor
they're this that and the other you you
relate
what do you like oh i i like uh jay-z or
whatever
it enables people that would not
necessarily have the opportunity to get
to know each other and understand hey
they're just like us we're dealing with
the same issues we're trying to get to
the same place
so you know the potential for sports to
uh overcome a lot of ignorance and uh
lack of knowledge of other people is is
huge
white americans did not ever see
a black american as having any value
especially heroic value until uh joe
lewis beats up max schmidling they liked
that
that was pretty good and all of a sudden
uh they looked upon black americans in
in a different way jackie robinson
breaks the color barrier in in baseball
people say well hey no he can play he
deserves he should be out there if he's
not out there that means that the best
baseball players are not playing major
league baseball that should change so
sports has that that potential and i
think for for that reason um it is a
good thing
especially as we know it here in america
and uh the things that it makes possible
for all of us in terms of understanding
and knowing each other
so kareem let me ask this this final
question to you and i'll move down so
everybody will get their final thoughts
when the donald sterling incident
happened you wrote the article time
magazine
i didn't understand half your big words
in there but it was a good article
the words i did understand read his
dictionary
so here's what i want to ask you
the incident became public on a saturday
saturday friday night saturday morning
we're in la on tuesday morning because
we hear the adam silver the commissioner
is about to make a ruling
i call you and your team the night
before we come down the city hall
you come to city hall
and we're in mark in mayor garcetti's
office
you
norm nixon ac green
steve nash
uh luke walton
all these great players there
what why was it so important for you to
be there at city hall
amongst your play and what were you
thinking right before
adam silver made his ruling i was
thinking that the nba has been my life
and i do not want some racist clown
being the face of the nba that that was
the one thing that got to me
and uh commissioner silver did such a a
great job i my first year in the league
i played in milwaukee
it was that year that they hired the
very first black general manager wayne
embry yeah of course and my whole life
since then i've seen the nba make more
and more reaching out
to be inclusive
and to open up doors
in the front office management uh in in
other areas where black americans
at one at one point were not considered
so i i know that the nba its heart is
right and it has tried to do the right
thing and if donald sterling is the face
of that something had to be done so
that's that's why i got on my horse
yeah round of applause for cream abdul
javar
all right mayor nutter i'm going to give
you the flexibility on your question
because
you know you're a mayor you have a
unique perspective you're dealing with
my brother's keepers you passionately
talked about violence in our communities
in a church and took everybody to task
we know this this race issue is real in
our country what what final thought do
you want to share to us
roland said something earlier i won't
keep going keep going
let me put a stop to that right now
i ain't scared of a brother
roland said something earlier uh and i
won't get it exactly right so
um
what he said
was talking about if a white
person
wants to talk about race or wants to get
into a race conversation
there may be some challenges
and
mayor johnson certainly knows this i
mean when we talk about my brother's
keeper city's united
challenges going on in
african-american communities for black
men and boys as it relates to violence
that you know
black men are six percent of the
population in the united states of
america 43 of the homicide victims i
mean it is an astounding
circumstance
question is
i mean mitch landrieu
mayor of new orleans
talks about this issue yes indeed
and he's white
just had a conversation last night with
the new mayor of boston marty walsh
wants to talk about this issue
and so the question is
especially for the african-american
community are you prepared to have that
conversation have someone who does not
look like you
talk about these things not
criticizing not blaming the victim
but
it's obviously a little easier for an
african-american mayor to talk about
black on black violence but i mean i get
a little bit of static back at home also
yep
it has to be triple worse
doubly difficult
for a
american leader mayor city council
member whatever to start talking about
black on black crime which could be a
very serious issue in your community and
have black folks jumping up talking
about why are you talking about that
so we have to create a safe and
comfortable space for folks to be able
to talk about real issues because what i
say to the mayors is look
somebody might criticize you for talking
about it i can i can assure you that
some folks will criticize you for not
talking about it
because death is death killings are
killings and shootings of shootings and
as mayors we have an obligation and
responsibility to deal with these very
serious issues so that door has to swing
both ways that field has to be open and
people have to be ready for a serious
conversation if we're going to truly do
our jobs and live up to the oath that
all of us took to be in these offices so
that's one
the second is
from time to time we read these stories
about now there's a team in washington
football team have a particular name
some people are offended
is this a real
issue
here in the country
should that issue be addressed and taken
on
in light of what's happened with the
clippers and all of this other you know
kind of stuff going on and that a
growing
proportion
of the american indian community
is in fact offended
by the name of the team in washington dc
that plays football
is that a real issue
it's a question so that's the question i
was actually going to ask
michael at this point no we work well
together we work well together so so
michael the question for you is
this broader context you played football
and those rivals rivalries cowboys
redskins cowboys redskins what is your
take on mayor nutter's question yeah and
uh and we talked about this and i you
know
again having these conversations or was
so involved was so vital
for years growing up in in fort
lauderdale with watching my dad who
loved the cowboys and
we watched cowboys redskins game and and
i didn't know
i didn't know as a young man i didn't
know that they were that was offensive
to them uh uh to to to
to to uh native americans i i didn't
know i didn't know so in getting that i
was like wow
you know this is the importance of
having it and and having those
conversations um
i i i want to have a conversation with
somebody to get an understanding of it
because because i still do not know but
if it offends somebody then we should do
something about it if we understand that
that's the great part of it and here's
the best part
even with
with the owner dan schneider i mean i
know they love making money it could
make a lot of money for them because
everybody that has all those redskins
things they got to get the new ones
so you can really satisfy both sides and
understanding that you know and and we
always
i i get caught with people all the time
you know the tradition of it the
tradition of it and i i appreciate
tradition and everything
but moving forward is what's important
and moving forward together is what's
important i believe a capitalist a
capitalist what uh
well if they're my last statement i want
to close with this let me close with
this because i want to go back to what
he said about 68 and everything and
we're talking about 40 years a little
over 40 years rolling was absolutely
correct i want us to
and we will take these moments and deal
with these tough spots these tough rubs
that we hear from the one of donald
sterling and people like that that would
invite these kinds of conversations
but as we leave here i want us leaving
with the right taste in our mouths
you know
60 and 68 a little bit past 40 years in
the bible they call that a generation
right the reality is we have to be
realistic in ex when we're expecting
change
and just because we start talking about
it and mentioning it doesn't mean it's
going to happen overnight there's a
reason god allowed the children of
israel to wonder for 40 years in the
desert to get the old land of slavery
out of them before they walked into the
new land of promise without the issues
of slavery on them we still have the
remnants of the donald sterlings and
we'll focus on the one but i don't want
us to miss the bigger point
and those 40 years
we can say it's not a big thing but it's
humongous i've seen african-americans
boohoo cried because they didn't think
it would be possible in their lifetime
of having an african-american
president and that happened in a little
over 40 years and we can focus on this
one dude donald sterling all we want or
we could be smart enough and focus on
what we all accomplished when we came
together as one that's what i think we
should do
that's my closing comment
i will
well
rolling to close us out with the final
thought
i sat a couple points i sat
um
on the set of cnn that night
and then when i was shedding tears folks
asked me why i said well first of all it
wasn't because of his election i see i
didn't do it because i saw him i saw
literally the u.s soldiers who were
hanging from trees and lynch in their
uniforms
that was the immediate image that came
to my mind
but the thing that i also said after
that because this also ties into sports
is that
i recognize that the inauguration parade
is over
if you have not read dr king's chaos or
community you should
because literally what we are talking
about today he wrote in 1967
when we were grappling with riots across
the country
what he said was it's real he said it
did not cost america much
didn't cost america much to allow us to
sit at the same lunch counter
or to be in the same hotel he said now
the question is the real cost
is about to be tabulated and is america
prepared to write that check
and he broke that whole thing down in
terms of where we are in terms of
society
and so when i look at opportunity when i
look at this idea of sports and how race
connects
what each and every single one of you
should do is do something that reverend
jackson often talks about
he said the reason african-americans
have been able to achieve a level of
success
in sports and entertainment he says
because in sports if it's basketball the
court is 94 feet for everybody
it's 10 feet high for everybody
shot clock is the same fouls are the
same everything is the same and so when
you go to play
your talent will determine whether you
succeed or not
it was undeniable that
kareem working on his game
was going to achieve the level of
success because in the game of sports
you can perform or you can't perform you
have the talent or you don't
same with michael
does not matter
but the real question that you should be
challenging people in your city and your
corporate citizens and your schools and
everyone else to say why is it that in
sports
rules are the same we can measure
success
but then off the court off the field it
goes from objective to subjective
where all of a sudden your talent does
not define whether or not you will
become an all-star
what somebody else is thinking defines
that
and so when i'm looking at the folks who
are ceos but not just oh my goodness we
have several african-american ceos but
i'm looking at how many black board
members there are how many hispanic
board members there are i'm looking at
who are the folks who are vice president
who is in the pipeline because what
we're still seeing in this country will
still we're still seeing an inequity in
terms of folks at the top and the bottom
when you look at right now in america
there's still not an african american
who is a prime time host of a cable news
network with a black man in the white
house is a problem for me
so what happens is we praise sports
because our sports figures worked on
their game achieved success because they
said if you run faster throw longer if
you can shoot better and rebound better
then you're going to start you're going
to succeed we should have the exact same
attitude in the rest of our society and
when that happens and we make it make it
make it uh
make it the point we preach all the time
then we'll see a closing of the racial
inequality gap when the average white
home has a hundred thousand dollars in
wealth the average african-american has
five thousand you won't see the issue of
subprime loans you won't see 53 percent
of black wealth wiped out in the last
six years because of home foreclosure
crisis and it would take two generations
to get just that money back
when we have that attitude about life as
we do about sports then we're going to
see it and i would be remiss to say we
should have the exact same attitude when
it comes to our sports teams we're
mayors out there you're building new
arenas for owners and you want them to
win championships and what you should be
saying when it comes to the education of
our children whether it's a question of
school choice and ad reform i want to
ensure that we have the same kind of
success so if you want to win a
championship in football or basketball
you sure as hell better win some
championships when it comes to educating
our children focus on that and that then
we are not going to be talking about
inequality in america but but sports is
leading the way right because now we got
five we got five owners in the four
major sports we only got six ceos and
four to five hundred couple seven and
five of the top 250 companies don't have
any african-americans on their board
only about two percent less than two
percent google doesn't facebook does it
doesn't i i've figured it may be here i
wasn't gonna name him but i'll let that
go he did that oh i named everybody
don't worry about it so so he's right in
that sense in sports we have such a
major amount of guys on the field that's
why we get a chance to talk about these
things and hopefully change all the
things we need to change but these
discussions are important before i let
them go and before you applied
um i wanted the honor to give as the
president of the u.s conference of
mayors we wanted to give the president's
award
to kareem jabar and the skyhook
foundation for all of his outstanding
work that he's doing around the country
let's give a round of applause for all
of our panelists and cream
[Applause]
thank you
um
[Music]
on this fourth of july arizona senator
john mccain at studentcam.org
next on american history tv we hear
about jesse owens and his legendary
performance in the 1936 berlin olympics
and how black athletes confronted nazi
white supremacy propaganda during the
games
this hour and 20-minute event was hosted
by the california african-american
museum in los angeles
good evening my name is steve clapholtz
and i'm the western regional director of
the united states holocaust memorial
museum with our offices located in los
angeles
first of all i want to tell you how
excited we are to be here tonight and
really thank our host the california
african american museum
the partnership between the united
states holocaust memorial museum and the
california african american museum has
been a wonderful wonderful experience we
have been treated so graciously and
we've been very excited about the crowds
of people who have come to the museum to
see the exhibit and i was talking to
dana who's in from washington that this
really is going to serve as a model for
the rest of the country in terms of the
partnerships between
between and among institutions in the
community so i want to thank again
the illustrious board member from the
california african american museum the
staff of the museum and just everyone
that we have worked with has been a
wonderful experience
the holocaust museum's traveling exhibit
politics race and propaganda hopefully
which all of you have seen the nazi
olympics berlin 1936
will be on view at the museum through
february 26th and we're so pleased to
take the opportunity tonight to cover
many issues that have really been
uncovered through the development of the
exhibit
more than 70 years since the end of
world war ii
the holocaust remains one of the most
singular events in global history
as a living memorial the united states
holocaust memorial museum continues its
efforts to make never again a reality
through programs in holocaust education
and genocide prevention
the museum and its supporters honor the
victims of the holocaust by working
towards solutions in today's complex
world
today we are facing an alarming rise in
anti-semitism
holocaust denial and ultimately genocide
even in the very lands where the
holocaust happened
this is occurring just as we approach
the time
when holocaust survivors and other
eyewitnesses will no longer be with us
sadly 70 years after the liberation of
the camps we are losing the eyewitnesses
and the holocaust survivors
this is why tonight's program and other
programming that we have done throughout
the country are very important
when we think about world events the
olympics are commonly viewed as an
opportunity for cross-cultural
appreciation and mutual respect
they are celebrated and embraced around
the world
80 years ago in august 1936
the world turned its attention to berlin
for the summer olympics the nazi regime
exploited the games to dazzle spectators
with an image of peaceful tolerant
germany
the u.s and other participants in the
olympics were forced to make a difficult
decision
condone a corrupt and prejudiced host or
boycott
what should have been a global
moment of friendly competition and
cooperation
this historic example exemplifies the
complexity of the relationships between
sports
international relations and human rights
while there was an organized boycott
many athletes around the globe opted not
to compete to protest in the years since
world war ii and the nazi olympics there
have been many opportunities for
protests both
at the olympics and at home surrounding
national sporting events
these expressions of both pro protests
as well as a victory in the field of
controversy
offer a poignant reflection point
tonight's distinguished panel which
we'll hear in a couple of minutes
we'll discuss the actions of individual
athletes from 1936 through present and
the challenges and opportunities that
arise when politics and sports intersect
it is my deep pleasure
tonight to introduce tonight's esteem
panel they include dr melinda abdullah
professor and chair of pan-african
studies california state university los
angeles she was appointed to the los
angeles county human relations
commission in 2014
and is a recognized expert on race
relations she is an organizer at the los
angeles branch of black lives matter
movement
susan bachrach is a historian and
exhibition curator with the united
states holocaust memorial museum
she developed a special exhibit on the
1936 berlin olympics and many others on
racial science and medicine
complicity and refugees and rescuers
and derek jackson essayist for the
boston globe and espn's the undefeated
and a full
2016 shorenstein fellow at harvard
university's kennedy school of
government
it is my pleasure to turn the program
over to our moderator history curator at
the california african american museum
tyree boyd page and again thank you and
welcome
thank you stephen appreciate that
[Applause]
we all live in a very special time
where police
athletes are intersecting
you see protests of famous athletes
explaining black lives matter and then
you also hear national responses as to
whether they do or they don't
this intersection isn't new
politics and race
um in sports um this has actually been
going on for much much longer than that
we have an exhibition circling the 1936
berlin olympics
where another individual tried to take a
stand his name was jesse owens
and we have brought some several
esteemed panelists who will
contextualize
that intersection between sports
race
and also allow us to engage in a more
powerful dialogue about how we all move
forward from there
so to begin i want to start off with
derek
who derek is a long time journalist
covering sports and race and can offer a
bit of context for us
in times of turbulence and rest
do we as americans look to athletes and
other public heroes for
guidance or inspiration
thanks a lot
[Laughter]
good evening everybody
um
it's for me it's a complex answer uh
because
there's a part of me uh that
uh certainly wish this didn't have to be
in this
as f as you frame
um
the
the
african-americans because of oppression
have been forced to
seek
ways to gain respect
acceptance
that white americans never had to do
and that's been a
unending story from
jack johnson
to jesse owens
to
um
john tommy smith john carlos
kareem abdul-jabbar
muhammad ali and even today
with lebron james um colin kaepernick
and um
it's
so
in a perfect world for instance
if there was a perfect world of
opportunity
the nfl would not be two-thirds black
the nba would not be 80
black
we'd have 13
basketball players football players we'd
also have 13 scientists
teachers
um
computer geeks
you name it
so i just needed to say that because
on one level
african-americans have been particularly
resistable using sports to seek respect
um and it also
is also has permanently been an unfair
playing field
so
the positive side in
trying to make this brief is
indeed
um african-americans
jesse owens trying to prove to hitler
and the nazis
our humanity and equality
muhammad ali giving up
the best years of his boxing career to
protest
induction into the military during
vietnam
lesser kind of forgotten is that many
athletes
boycotted
um some other olympics
and
um
so
the potent because we
in america as a general society
uh put sports on a pedestal that also
is exaggerated
to the point of being ridiculous
i think you all know about your gaining
and losses of football teams over the
years with owners holding the taxpayers
hostage build me a stadium or else
so sport the whole nature of sports as a
business is also political
and
so within that context it has been
important
for
black athletes to speak out when they
can
technically an athlete is the only thing
they owe you and me is their performance
on the field but because of all those
other inequalities that i mentioned
um it has been one of this country's
greatest and most important assets when
those athletes do speak out
susan
good evening well i
i think all your points are are well
taken um
but it jogged my mind a little bit with
regard to um jewish athletes during
these 1936 olympics
and what it meant politically
for jewish athletes
not only from the u.s but from some of
the european countries that were going
to the games
could they
in good conscience
go to those games
knowing what was going on in the
persecution of
uh jews in germany so
that became a real conflict too for some
of those athletes
even after
a very serious effort to boycott these
games if you go in the exhibit you can
see it really failed by just a hair no
one remembers it because it failed
but it was the first serious
boycott
effort for for an olympics
um
but even after that um
before that a number of jewish athletes
decided that they were not going to
compete in the trials even though they
were olympic caliber
their times or whatever indicated they
would have qualified they chose not to
and there was a political effort a very
organized effort to inform those
athletes about what was going on
far away because maybe they weren't so
well informed and they were young and
all they cared about was really was
their sport in winning
but at the same time you still had a
group of
um
six
jewish americans who ended up going
including marty glickman who became very
famous
later on in life as a professional
sports announcer and he tells his story
in in in the
exhibit they decided
to go
um
and oh in california
the jewish community here um
uh in the newspaper were very upset that
sam balter a jewish basketball player
participated
um they didn't mince words so it became
a very large political issue in a in a
different way i think it was complicated
for african americans and there was some
african american press that was very
anti-nazi
and they didn't support
um you know the athletes going either
but
it is it's a complicated story
especially when athletes uh
they've
competed they've trained and the moment
arrives and it's very hard to say
i'm not going to go
and susan to that point how did
the olympics even end up in berlin and
we'll bring in molina very shortly after
that
while berlin was chosen when it was
still
a democratic republic
as we know the international olympic
committee chooses uh the host city years
before the event because of all the
planning so it was hitler took power in
1933 after it had been chosen two years
after being chosen so then did the
decision
should we stick with berlin or not and
and so that's that again is a story that
we tell um
there was a big discussion about that
interesting and so you were
sharing that
there was a boycott going on
during that time in 1936 in germany
um in the u.s
and there was it was part of a larger
um
boycott that was organized organized
here of um german goods
and the olympics and going to the
olympics was folded into that larger
boycott
that
what came from labor organizations labor
was was um the trade unions were were
abolished and the independent trade
unions are abolished
from jewish groups and also from
anti-nazi
groups so it was
it was an effort
of a coalition of groups wow wow thank
you
to molina um as she paints that picture
uh what was the picture like for african
americans and how were they treated at
the time in the u.s
right
so let me just say thank you for having
me on this panel i don't know why i'm on
it because i have nothing to do with
sports like
i watch the super bowl for the
commercials
[Laughter]
but now that i've rate your piece i'll
be watching so that i make sure atlanta
wins right
i think that
as we talk about black athletes it's
really important for us so i assume my
role here is not to be a sports expert
but
i do study questions of black power and
so i assume my role is to kind of um lay
out what the world looked like for black
people in 1936 in 1968 but also to kind
of have a conversation about sports and
politics now and so that's why i'm
wearing my
i do know the names of a few athletes
right so i've never seen kaepernick play
i've only seen him not stand up right
[Laughter]
um
so i think it's important that we
understand that black people
even though
a society which is really rooted in
white supremacy often tries to cast
athletes and other black folks who
occupy public spaces is things right as
athletes who are seen for their bodies
and who are not to have any minds right
who are to be um
enthusiastic endorsers of their own
oppression right um
[Music]
i think we are trained to see athletes
in that way right it's just the black
body right and so there's a resentment
since where we we started to all work
backwards thinking about people like
kaepernick but even thinking about
people like marshawn lynch right um
who
don't comply who don't conform who are
not enthusiastic about their oppression
right
um
there's a um tendency there's a
structure
built to say they are they are supposed
to just be bodies and they're not
supposed to have minds and think and
they're not supposed to have connections
with anyone beyond themselves there's
this piece that's kind of a holdover
from chattel slavery of natal alienation
this idea that black people should not
be connected with each other right and
so if we think about 1936 if we think
about what jesse owens was supposed to
do what black athletes were supposed to
do we also have to understand what's
happening in 1936 the harlem renaissance
is dying down right um but there are
real questions about black people in our
role as laborers as workers what the
civil rights look like in this country
and there's an assumption
that black people should be prioritizing
the liberation of other people really
ahead of our own liberation right and
someone else is kind of um determining
what freedom struggle is supposed to
look like and so there's this kind of
complicated narrative around black
athletes at the time um
[Music]
should jesse owen stand in solidarity
with the jewish athletes should jesse
owen stay home should he boycott right
and then there's a whole black community
that doesn't really have the answers
right black organizations saying you
know boycott or don't boycott you know
family members saying you know well we
need you to be your best self this
kind of tension between individual and
familial advancement and what is your
obligation to community and so i think
that we can think about it and begin it
historically by talking about 36
but we can also go further back in
history and then we can also move
forward in history and i know we'll be
talking about 68 we'll be talking about
the contemporary period as well but i
just want to kind of frame it in that
way as
black athletes is representing um
or experiencing this um
desire by white supremacy to separate
the black body from the black mind
let me just follow up with something
really important absolutely here we go
guys
think of the reaction the national
reaction when kohler kaepernick
peaceful protest kneeling before the
national anthem
he didn't hurt nobody right he didn't
shoot nobody and it was a national
firestorm
to tell him get up and and and um
and salute the flag
go to another country
um
contrast that
and let me just a couple other when jim
brown retired
um at the height of the prime of his
career
because he had an independent mind
people said
are you crazy retiring
um i grew up in milwaukee
uh when lual cinder changed his name to
korean abdul-jabbar and that caused
major
um
um
blowback from white fans in milwaukee at
the time
so
what you said about
the
the the nature of this
national beast to get black people to
not think independently for themselves
and you contrast that to i wrote a
column to smoke today in the boston
globe about
the fact that uh
the new england patriots top three
figures
bill belichick the coach the owner of
robert kraft and the quarterback tom
brady
all are uh pals of donald trump
and how
so far they've been able to
um not not been forced to own up to any
not offered a word of blowback or
pushback to any of trump's behavior
um during these uh the two years that
trump has been
um
running for president so
you just contrast that
with the um
outrage
from many sectors over
and and the firestorm that kaepernick's
simple kneeling did
and that tells you a lot about where
this country is still at interesting you
can argue just let me say this so this
is why i say
the requirement is enthusiastic
endorsement of our oppression right
because kaepernick
really people called it a protest
that's not really a protest right to
refuse to stand
for a national anthem that is rooted in
the oppression of your people
that's i mean that's claiming humanity
right that's that's just the refusal to
endorse your oppression that's not
really protesting in my view now he's
gone further and really kind of talked
about why he's done that um
but
i think that that kind of requirement is
is is something that we really need to
think about
and i love your piece everybody should
read this this piece yeah
everybody will be rooting for the
atlanta falcons
yes you will yes you will
uh susan and if you want to have a
response to that i have a question for
you right after that
i am a die-hard new england patriots fan
new england girl
[Laughter]
yeah but it is putting a little
color on things that
no pun intended
no pun intended
but what you are saying i'm getting some
very strange associations because i
usually don't share the stage with such
thoughtful peop political people too
it's wonderful um
the
gesture symbolic gesture is interesting
because um
and i had a lot of conversations with
friends around the time the the uh colin
carpenter thing because people always
come to me because
to get the nazi angle
on these things
and um
interesting and
you know you had to start thinking about
the hitler salute
and the pressures to conform that were
so enormous
and even if there wasn't a law that you
were supposed to do that the norm had
established this
and there's a very there's a great
famous photo to some of us in the field
that is a huge crowd of germans giving
the salute and there's one figure
in that crowd who has not he has that's
his protest by not
giving the salute and i think the larger
issue with um the you know beyond the
one that you were talking about has to
do with with conformity in certain
situations and how
you know the national anthem has has
become used and the pressures are so
great
for for people um you know in
even if you're not
uh having some particular political
cause at the moment and we're supposed
to be an utterly free society
where you know freedom of expression is
is is permitted and i i think that
should always
be in my mind um
the the standard um
let's talk a little bit more about
conformity and the pressures that it has
on athletes um
during that time um why recognizing the
pressure that jesse owens was under why
did the united states decide to send him
and other athletes to berlin despite
this controversy and the con the
conformity that
that period of time was inflicting on
many
um
well there was one very important figure
involved whose name has really become
identified with the uh olympic movement
in the 20th century
and his name was avery brundage
and
he was a lifelong
supporter of the olympics starting with
his participation as an athlete in the
1912 games in stockholm
and he thought
very sincerely that sports and politics
could somehow exist and
coexist and that they were
separate things so that that's a
question that we often
asked when we talk about this this
subject with students
you know
is there can sports be separate from
from politics can art be separate from
politics you know the big existential
questions um
so
uh he really uh organized and worked
very hard to to make sure that the uh
eventual vote that was by the amateur
athletic union um went in favor of
participation it was very very close
but he put a lot of energy
he even went on a tour of germany and
had interviews with athletes and coaches
to try to determine if they were being
fair and following the rules and
allowing you know
uh
jews to
qualify for the team and so forth it was
all very well staged managed and came
back and said fine fine fine so went
through all the motions to try to get
people to con convince them that this
should
go on and in terms of jesse owens
um i don't know if any of you saw the
there was a biopic um that came out
earlier this year the jesse owens story
that really focused on this moment
and it presented him as being very very
conflicted about it
um
but because he there is a statement that
he did come out with initially and say
um well if you know
they're racist i'm not sure we should go
and so forth um
but i think
in his case
uh there were a lot of pressures put on
him on all sides um and in the end
probably the one his coach put on him
turned out to be the most important
his coach was like a second father to
him and was very very influential
person
um so
i i think that probably um
won the day there but you know i think
it was a matter of a more complex issue
for those athletes because they really
did feel that if they they went they
could make a statement
um
you know about so-called aryan supremacy
and whether you know this was the case
or not
and those games they went off despite
mass protests and black athletes on the
u.s team brought home the victory as we
all know from jesse owens
excellent performances but to molina
did their victory serve as some form of
protests in opposition to that nazi
regime and what did their victories
really accomplish
um
it depends
it depends on how you interpret
interpret things right
does the
um
do those victories
mean anything right and then i think
that one of the things that happens when
they come home is they recognize that
there's still this they're not elevated
at home right there's still the the
treatment of african people in the
united states that's very real and very
stark even for olympic
athletes right and so it's important to
remember that it's important to remember
that our athletes um are often used to
pretend as if the conditions that we
live under are not the conditions that
we live under right and so um i think
that
we need to think about that in 1936
we're still coming home to the first
wave of lynching the first lynching era
is still in full effect in 1936 right um
and um so i think it to a degree
elevates the consciousness of um
black people knew what we lived under
but we uh what's the saying hope springs
eternal right like
we recognize what we live under and this
has been true for the duration of our
residency in this country right
we understand the conditions that we
live under
we experience these conditions there's
this reality but still there's this hope
there's this hope if we just do this if
jesse owens just brings home the gold
right
then it'll be all better for black
people in the u.s but that's never the
case it doesn't better his condition
right and it's important that we
understand that most black olympic
athletes wind up living in poverty right
we need to understand that that they're
elevated for a moment
but
they live like the rest of black people
after that moment is done right and so
even in terms of individual advancement
it's momentary individual and
advancement and so it's important that
we recognize that i think that that's
kind of what we saw this this hope that
it would advance us collectively or
individually beyond the moment um but
that
did not happen
that resonates with me um if anyone of
you've seen the movie race uh there is a
scene toward the end of the film where
the actor jesse owens and his wife come
back after winning the gold and he has
to go through the back door of his own
celebratory
dinner and that move
that that scene was very powerful to me
because it explains that exceptionalism
that one might feel
coming back home but under still some
political duress 1936 we're not even
close to ending the era of jim crow
we're not even close right so we have to
think go all the way 30 years forward
before the civil rights movement really
takes hold and begins to topple some of
those structures some of those american
apartheid structures that are
experienced by even those who are deemed
exceptional susan you you look like
you're about to share something actually
yeah
i don't know that much about sports
history but i have studied these black
athletes and i because i know there are
some young people in the crowd i think
it's important to point out that the
black olympians who
went on and
got graduate degrees and there were a
number of them who did
they
ended up in professional
positions owens didn't even finish
college
so
you know i think that that was one
issue but
you're right of course i mean um
john woodruff who was a medalist he came
back he was not allowed to compete
at um the us naval academy wow in a in a
meet you know so
it's really important to remember those
moments but i do wonder in terms of the
history
if it's part
of
the arc
you know
of movement um
you know
owens and others are said to have
inspired
you know subsequent generations of
athletes
did we were talking earlier about
the delayed integration of the
professional sports teams but you know
did this have some impact on that i i
don't know but it's just a question
i'd ask and can i compound that question
a little bit
for that for you as well because it's
coming straight to you it's derek it's
coming to you um molina is is kind of
asking us let's fast forward 30 years
right because if 1936 is not a good
context it's the first wave of lynching
but if we fast forward 30 years to 1968
the olympic games when gold medalist
tommy smith and bronze medalist john
carlos famously raised their black
gloved fist during the national anthem
in a statement of black pride
while this was completely different
circumstances we have a major global
sporting event at the center of a very
public political statement
how derek
was this statement perceived by the
global athletic community by the
majority of americans and ultimately by
the majority of black americans
well since they were thrown out of
mexico city you know
um
no i mean i remember to the i was 13 at
the time and i remember watching it live
and uh being profoundly proud of these
guys
and um
uh
so it's a great question
um
i think
there's no doubt in my mind
that
that action inspired
hundreds of thousands if not a few
million
young african-americans to
be strong and wherever you're at and
whatever you're doing
and um
and that you could speak truth to power
um
most of us did not do it with a black
glove fist
but we did it in other ways
and
and he remember that 68 um was right
there also that was at the time that ali
was barred from from boxing or he
actually was yeah
67-70 yeah so ali was out
um
that olympics
i believe if i'm right correct me if i'm
wrong kareem and other
athletes refused to go
um that was the lesser known
kind of protest over those olympic games
um
and
so
again
and
obviously huge swaths of white america
were outraged over that but
that also raised consciousness about
what is this anger about
um
what's going on
um
so i look at it as a wonderful moment
of athletes using that podium platform
to
say something is wrong in this country
i'm running for this country abroad and
yet when i go home
either me or my folks are facing
something terrible so
again that's why i say athletes are not
necessarily sometimes you don't want an
athlete to open their mouth
but when they do and they do powerfully
when they do and do it in the right
context or the most powerful context
on
right or wrong
because of the disproportionate presence
that we have in sports
it matters a whole lot
thank you uh and to melina are public
statements like john carlos's black
fisted glove pumping in the air um
are are those generally perceived in a
positive light and
are those men considered heroes today
and always
i mean it again it depends on by who so
i want to acknowledge my dad is here
who was an athlete during that time a
college athlete at
uc berkeley
and we were talking in the car and i was
like quick give me a crash course on
what was happening
hey dad um
and i asked him you know did john carlos
and tommy smith did they serve as
inspirations for you
and one of the things we need to think
about is how the difference between how
black folks
experience something
and how
white
society experiences something so for us
yeah they're absolutely heroes and
inspirations and continue to be right um
my dad one of the things that he talked
about kind of feeling conflicted by as a
student athlete at berkeley um was like
this pull he was an athlete but he was
also
there's a whole black power movement
going on right 68 is a beautiful year
it's a it's a very difficult year as
well but it's a beautiful year right 68
is the year that
black studies was born
68 is the year that we see you know the
black power movement really take
full hold on society and we need to
think about tommy smith and john carlos
as both um contributors to the black
power movement but also
beneficiaries of the black power
movement one of the things that my dad
was pointing to
is that um they went to san jose state
where they had the opportunity to be
educated by people like harry edwards
right who could ground them in what does
it mean to have voice right and i think
this is i i picked up on what you said
when you say sometimes we don't want
them to speak right
but that you have a right to speak right
now you made me think about malcolm's um
statement malcolm x's statement about
you know only in black community does
you know the white press or white power
holders go to athletes and entertainers
and pretend like they're leaders and say
well what do you think about blah blah
blah nobody ever goes to a white
trumpeter and asks him what he thinks
about politics right um but i think that
what's pointed to and what we see with
john carlos and tommy smith is there's a
difference between
the anointment and condoning
of
um black athletes and black public
figures as our leaders
and the willingness and um kind of
volition
they're moving forward on their own
volition and deciding to step up so i
think that was what
we recognized and why we in the black
community continue to see tommy smith
and john carlos as heroes thank you for
the answer and and to susan
going back
we're in a time machine going back 30
more years before 68. yeah for me that's
going back raise your hand if you
remember 36
it's not um
for that um in 36 what effect did the
berlin olympics have overall
within the international community and
was it the propaganda successful that
hitler hoped it would be
in a
eradicating a lot of conversation
well
in established germany as a legitimate
player on the world stage instead of a
pariah state which may have been the
case if people had not gone
although counterfactual history is
always difficult what if
so
and
what was also very important is the nazi
movement was really a youth movement in
in large part
and
in 1936 the nazi regime had only been in
power for three years it was still
consolidating its support
and so it was very important to the
consolidation of
german youth that were
very important in it and a lot of the
nazi leaders were young too
um
to have them
see that the world was coming to germany
for this
these games
another thing is that um
german hospitality was praised they
rolled out the welkin
welcome wagon
um
the black athletes were very well
treated they said they were better
treated there
certainly than they were back home
um
and it it was all very beautiful and
the german athletes if you look at the
metal tally they won the most overall
so
i think the story of owens is is is
important in in any number of ways but
it's also been used as kind of the feel
good american way to look at this
history
now in 36
people didn't know the holocaust was
going to happen
either war hadn't come yet that
genocide hadn't happened
so it's easy to look back
and think
but but still the character that regime
and that dictatorship
you know was was quite well known at the
time and our diplomats were advising us
not to send a team they knew the
diplomats who were there and reporting
on it
so um and they talked a lot about youth
too
and how
it was it was very important for that so
i think uh the consensus is that
actually it was
a propaganda success wow and so thinking
about propaganda and political
statements um derek if we think of
sporting events as the spectacles for
opportunities to share certain messaging
as hitler did in 36
do the athletes have responsibility to
speak out against
for and endorse those these type of
propaganda and political statements that
go out
yikes
that's a big question
um
let me just repeat i think
in the abstract
you know athletes technically
always nothing but their performance on
the field
that's
in a country that is equal
and
there's not any particular amount of um
duress stress
friction divisiveness racism
on all that
last i heard we don't live in a country
like that right
and
in fact president obama
was quite pleased
um with
he said it was a good thing that lebron
james colin kaepernick
and the modern athletes were beginning
to speak out about police brutality
and inequality in this country and he
hoped that there'd be more of it
so
you know the
the nation's top basketball fan for
eight years
um
actually obliquely he didn't directly
criticize michael jordan
but he hearkened back to about 20 years
15 20 years ago when
black the voice of black athletes was
fairly absent
from public discourse
and i think i personally think that
should athletes
who in terms of black men
are the richest you know the richest
black men in the country um for the most
part uh there are many black businessmen
and business women who on who on unknown
in this room make lots of money as well
but
um
[Music]
should black athletes
with their money with their clout
with their public exposure and influence
with their vastly disproportionate
presence on the field
they do have a
latent power unlike any other subset of
african americans in this country
um and so
we live at a time when
disparities
are
arguably depending how you measure them
are higher now
than 20 30 years ago
we have people here we have people
here
in ways that should not be
so
i think that
should the lebrons
should the
um
um other athletes top athletes i was
really impressed even though it's not as
wasn't as prominent because the women's
sports are not as played up in our
sports pages the women wnba
the black the wnba's support for black
lives matter was just absolutely amazing
um i think what was really cool about
this modern moment is that
kaepernick's gesture was picked up not
just by black players but by white
soccer players
um some of the top stars it um
so it spread to other um it's not it's
not just a black thing
and i think this this recognition of
disparities and
the fact that um
[Music]
depending on the behavior of our new
president um
who i'm just going to say who who
nominated a attorney general
who was rejected for a federal judgeship
in the 1980s because of his alleged
racist statements
our civil rights laws are now in those
hands
i say we would need all hands on deck
and that includes the athletes
that deserves applause right great
and derek that was the perfect segue
into my final questions for you all um
in the years since world war ii
there have been many opportunities to
protest both at the olympics and at home
just to name a few muhammad ali and the
vietnam war 1968's olympic statement of
black power
discussions of protests around sochi
winter olympics recent protests in u.s
in the u.s associated with black lives
matter i.e colin kaepernick
my question to you all is many americans
are offended
by the very idea of athletes making
political statements
however athletes themselves are citizens
of the world with a social conscience
and a freedom of expression
are these displays of protests
courageous
or disruptive
and i'll give this to molina first
well i think courage and disruption are
sometimes the same thing it's courageous
to be disruptive
we have to disrupt systems of oppression
we have to
and
i think that the work that athletes are
doing
some athletes are willing to do to open
their mouths and say you know speak out
against injustice is really important
work um w.e.b du bois once wrote that
all art is propaganda right
but it's also important to remember i
think the point of his statement
is that the way in which we interact
with art and culture and i'd add sports
to that
is all propaganda we're always
considering whose side we're on
so
if the athletes especially black
athletes just play
they're
endorsing a system that says they're no
more than a black body right when they
use their voice when they say i'm going
to use this stage to elevate a cause and
i'm going to speak out on behalf of my
people
i think that's part of our sacred duty
and i think that's
what we're seeing happen more and more
and my hope is
that people won't crumble
and
and
bow down to a regime that says we don't
have the right to use our voice um the
one thing that i want to add and i heard
you say um in 1936 we didn't know that
there was going to be a holocaust right
i hope we learn the lesson
um and as we're considering or the um
international olympic committee is
considering where to put the 2020
olympics i think that will i hope that
they'll see parallels
um
we already have banned countries now
right
so to say
that the olympics should come to los
angeles or any other place in the united
states i think is something that they
have to weigh recognizing history
recognizing the severity of the
oppression and um
the very vocal and dangerous rhetoric
and actions coming out of this white
house i hope that both individual
athletes but also sports communities
viewers
will
use whatever we have our purchasing
power our viewing power and the athletes
the platform um and the mic when they
have it to speak out against it thank
you susan
[Applause]
um
i think it takes courage in many
situations to speak out when you're
going against the crowd
i think it's true for athletes they face
so many pressures
um including the well-paid ones
um
and they have their bran i mean
commercial pressures they have their
brand to protect they have their
precious coming from their team their
owners so many different pressures
and i
think
all of us in our daily lives
face many different pressures to just
kind of go along and not to stand out
and
to speak up when we see injustice and
i think one of the warnings and the
messages of our museum really is to get
people to think about those moments and
to kind of prepare for them because
if you don't prepare for that moment
when it's going to come then then maybe
you won't have the courage that it takes
to
to stand up and
because it does take courage it
definitely takes courage so
it takes courage and um
i
re and it's probably disruptive too
thank you very much derek
when i was a kid
i grew
um
it actually unspoken inspiration from
watching the green bay packers
um
um because in a in a serious way that i
did not understand until many many years
later
um
at that time the green bay packers in
the 60s under vince lombardi were
actually one of the most integrated
teams in pro football
in green bay wisconsin
city that even today is only 100 000
people in its municipality
i didn't know this until many years
later but vince lombardi
um and we're not talking about black
athletes now we're talking about
i wanted to switch just a little bit
because i wanna there is a
responsibility of white athletes
white coaches white owners as well
um because it's too easy to put black
athletes out there on a limb on the
gangplank and say you boy you protest
meanwhile while craft brady and
belichick
are going to trump tower
um vince lombardi
went um he heard that there was some
discrimination in the restaurants in
milwaukee in downtown green bay
and he went there
according to david marines's great book
on him
and by the way lombardi was not a saint
he had a lot of demons in his family
life
he went there and said to the he called
the restaurant owners together says any
restaurant that does not serve all of my
any of my green bay packers serves none
of my green bay packers
and that piece of leadership
led to black players wanting to play in
green bay
a place that otherwise
i grew up in the state i can talk about
it um
and many years later
um
many years later
a majority black team is playing in
green bay
and um uh winning still winning
championships every few years and coming
so close um
but i love my hail mary passes so um
so i do think i just wanted to say that
one thing because this is when i said
all hands on deck i didn't mean all
black people right i meant i mean so for
instance one reason i'm rooting for the
falcons is because arthur blank has
pushed back against the trump phenomenon
even though he's an nfl owner
um
so
it's it's really really important to put
it's okay to ask our black athletes
our latino athletes our athletes of
color to speak out about injustice
but we should also put the same energy
into urging our the white leaders who
run these teams
to also speak out for injustice
well thank you all guys give him a round
of applause
for justice for for justice thank you
for that
well i just want to say thank you um
both all for shedding light on this
pivotal moment in american history and
global history and i hope that we can uh
take these words that you all said that
we all have some ownership to take and
both to be courageous to disrupt and
also to move forward as a community so
give them all a round of applause
[Music]
now it's out to my favorite part of the
evening we want to open up um it to the
entire audience to ask questions of our
panelists these experts so
um we are gonna figure out how we're
gonna do this do we have an extra mic my
man yes um if you'd like can we set up
the mic right here in the middle and
we'll let's get a line of about three to
five people to ask questions and you can
line up at the microphone and again
let's make uh these questions very
they're questions not comments
maybe you maybe
and if you have a question you are an
unable body if you aren't able-bodied we
can bring the mic over to you just raise
your hand
okay
okay
okay i'd like to say that i'm
i was a history major
and i just want to comment on a few
things that the panelists said
when john is is this a question or a
comment it's a comment we will can we
get to the questions first and then we
can ask the comments because this is a
question portion okay okay i have to be
the moderator right now yes
yes i thank you for coming and i really
have enjoyed uh this panel
i would like to know from each one of
you very short
answers
why do you think america could
accept and i guess vote for
a president
that has said all kinds of things about
people
but had difficulty
accepting a person kneeling
just to say
you know i don't agree
with uh what might be happening
in our society
there and we'll give about 20 seconds to
each enter 30 seconds sure um
i've
the short answer a really short answer
that would need
more elaborations that
um
after eight years of the first black
president of the united states
a certain subset of americans couldn't
handle it
and but i would have said
that what it might it might have been
25 30 based on voting based on surveys
about what people think about police
brutality all kind of stuff
unfortunately
the new president during his campaign
figured out a way
to play
on the worst
fears and worst
aspects of american society and whipped
up
issue after issue
mexican immigrants
uh over here
other
muslims over there whipped up
hysteria
against so many groups of people that it
unfortunately had added up to a point
where even with the misogyny of the
access hollywood tape
um 56
of
white women voted for trump
susan
um
well i
i think that people have to
learn
to
look at statements that are being made
publicly and
to be informed and try to
critically think about those and and
i'm not sure that that was done as much
as could be and i i think that this was
such a different kind of candidate it
was
and so unconventional that it might
have been very hard for people to do
that
but i think we need people to think
very very
critically and
to to make
maybe better informed uh decisions but
in terms of analyzing the elections i
i'm afraid it's really
beyond my pay grade and it's um
it's a matter of
uh speculation and repeating what i've
read in the news for why this happened
um so i wrote a longer piece on this
that came out on inauguration day called
black liberation in the era of trump so
if you want a longer analysis it's fair
um but i think that this is not the
first time that this happened so we
talked about 68 right we need to
remember who was elected president in 68
right
nixon's election in 68 we also have
parallels with the current iteration of
the black liberation movement in 68
we're in the midst of the black power
movement right so the short answer why
this happened why they want to
silence and demonize black athletes
like colin kaepernick and black public
folks who have a stage right who dare to
speak out
even people like beyonce right
why they want to do that
is the same reason that trump was
elected so the short answer is white
supremacy
that
we live in a white supremacist society
very little has changed um and we need
to recognize it
just a brief follow-up to that um i
think you just look at who is his chief
advi his uh stephen bannon
from the alt-right which is a euphemism
for young racist young racists
um
but i think one thing that we all she
ought to take responsibility for if you
didn't want trump
um
we also have to you know i think the
kids now say stay woke
um
okay let's not forget i hear that
sometimes yes
we say we say that i don't know who's in
colloquialism i know i'm not but no
seriously um
the this the nation people who want the
better angels to run government cannot
go to sleep um
uh everybody was slap happy when obama
got elected in 2008
people stayed home in the mid-term 2000
midterms the republicans got the house
everybody got slapped happy when obama
was reelected people went back to sleep
in 2014 the republicans got the senate
now they have all three chambers and
part of that is on us
well let me say though it's also on them
right because i'm sorry
i
the
candidate the democratic candidate who
has garnered the least amount of
enthusiasm in my lifetime
is hillary clinton nobody voted for
hillary clinton everybody who voted who
cast their ballot for clinton was just
voting against trump right so
okay so maybe you two um
but i think that there is a this idea so
this idea and you asked for my ideas so
let me share my ideas and then you can
share yours right
this idea that it's just republicans
against democrats is a very very flawed
model right the democrats um you know
they like to um say black folks are
wrong for not being as enthusiastic
about clinton as they were about obama
right clinton did not represent
liberation for us
she did not she was just better than the
kind of oppressive um and vocal and um
neo kkk member that trump is right she
knew how to kind of check it and tailor
it and make it politically correct but
the truth is our liberation has to be
something bigger than the democratic
party and if the democratic party wants
us to endorse them and support them
enthusiastically
they gotta do better by us
[Music]
thank you we have one more question
do we have any more questions after this
and you'll be the final one
unless anyone is who is an able-bodied
has a has a question and we can bring
the mic over to you okay
hi my name is melinya i'm a former
division one athlete which might give
you a little insight into my existing
opinions on this question i'm gonna ask
you molina
can you please elaborate on your
comments earlier on in the in the
presentation about marshawn lynch and
presumably other professional athletes
who
are talking about their enthusiastic
endorsement of their oppression so what
would you say to someone who just walks
off the street and says these guys are
millionaires like where is the
oppression in this situation what would
you say to
that
so i think that so i don't think
marshawn lynch is i i want to just
clarify i don't think marshawn lynch i
think he resists then
refuses to enthusiastically endorse our
oppression so when i say his own
oppression i'm really also accepting
michael dawson's um view of linked fate
right that black people
more than any other group see our
collective freedom rather than
individual liberation so marshawn lynch
is still black he's still from oakland
i'm from oakland so i especially like
marshawn lynch right um
but i think that um what they were
requiring of marshawn lynch was for him
to kind of be a new millennium [ __ ]
right and that's what they require of a
lot of athletes and entertainers right
smile and dance
right smile and dance and if you refuse
to smile and dance
then
you are kind of bucking oh wow that's a
pun bucking the system right
um and so it's it's really important
that we understand that that um even
though athletes are well paid
there's still oppression that's
experienced right this idea that if you
don't dance we're gonna take it all away
is oppressive and so i think that i'm
very impressed with lynch's decision to
say okay look i got enough i'm stepping
back and this is what i'm going to do
now right and i think that angers them
even more because it means it's less
power that they're holding over him i i
just think it's important to add to the
there's a difference between uh one of
my buddies uh bill former new york times
columnist bill rhoden wrote a great book
called uh 40 million dollar slaves
and
i think
the thing that is still not
fundamentally changed in this country in
the sports structure is that the sports
structure is still
black and actually even more so than
years ago
two-thirds of nfl players are black
80 or so of nba players are black
the ownership
um and coaching structure is still
vastly disproportionate white
the the agents
are vastly disproportionately white
i have a cousin who was a sports agent
and it it was just hell to compete
he did he was successful for many years
um
so there i think we have to look past
the money i think in terms of
of of structures
i would say that college d1 sports is
actually far worse
um so i know we're running out of time
but for instance i was gonna i will do a
quiz people are shocked every time i
give this quiz how much do you think um
is spent on academic spending on an
ordinary student at d1 the answer is
fifteen thousand dollars how much do you
think auburn spent on a football player
um
a quick one somebody says
keep going
well not quite a million five hundred
and eleven thousand dollars
okay 32 times more
so
that's right and the coaches are making
nfl salaries and so when the coaches are
making nfl salaries
they're spending half a million on a
player and the player gets what maybe a
scholarship maybe a grant maybe a degree
maybe
um so
that to me if you want to talk about
sort of systems of
i don't use the word oppression as much
as exploitation exploitation that's
exactly i would the system is
still yeah and my yeah yeah and with the
brain damage and all that in football so
um again that's
the big picture is it's still
exploitative thank you uh look we're
gonna take three more questions a year
the first one we had two more two and
who was the third
she had a comment yes and i we can't
forget her of course thank you and you
will be you will round us out your
comment will round us out okay
after uh john carlos and tommy smith by
the way great socks
i like his actually yeah okay these old
things
after
barring the republic of south africa
from participating in the olympics
after
muhammad ali
and looking back 80 years
later
what is the lesson of the 1936 olympics
and what is the future of politics in
the olympic movement
and we'll try to get one minute
responses for that one
uh what is the future well you know i i
thought the olympics have almost run its
course myself as it became more and more
commercialized um over the years um
and also the the whole issue of security
now no one really
wants
the cost to become so great and
communities don't want to support the
the building of the facilities and the
stadiums so
um
i i i don't know was that your question
the future of the olympics or
politics
yeah the thing about the olympics is
that it's all it is a world stage that
makes it different
i mean the super bowl is a pretty big
stage too that kind of but the olympics
bringing all the countries together it's
i think it's it's a little bit
distinctive now we have the world cup i
don't know if there's anything
comparable to that okay so i think it's
totally
possible it just depends on the moment
if you look through the whole history
there are many political moments in the
olympics and there's something political
probably about every single one of them
thank you susan
sir
so uh thank you all of you great socks
[Music]
hi i'm a big soccer fan um in fifa the
organizing body of soccer they have
say no to racism is a thing that gets
pushed out during the world cup and
today i was reading something that said
um it's
less uh it's more of a problem for
somebody to be called a racist than it
is to actually be racist so how do we
get from
where it's a taboo thing to be called
racist or to be perceived as racist
than to actually be racist and i want to
add a one other comment that's maybe not
super related but i think it's it ties
into the 1936 olympics and
actually something in the first world
war where the harlem hell fighters were
these fighters mostly uh i think it's
two-thirds were from harlem black
fighters that had to be in their own
units because they were segregated but
they got that name from the germans that
they fought because they were that
uh that had that much prowess on the
battlefield
um so when we talk about these wars or
these major historical events
what
what do you think
we need to do to show that there's
nuance that
in the at the end of the day in the
olympics it didn't matter that jesse
owens had his victory that's a feel-good
story that we tell ourselves
i'm long-winded with it but i think you
guys
so i can take the first part of the
question if that's okay
um
so the answer to all questions like that
is white supremacy every answer is white
supremacy right so the idea that we
should be coddling people
who say but i'm not a racist because
nobody thinks they're a racist right
except the ones who actually wear sheets
they know they're racist but they they
don't even want to be called racist
publicly right
um so they don't want to be called
racist and so the idea that we should be
coddling them
um that we should be caring about what
we call white tears right
more than
um we care about the black people the
brown people the indigenous people who
are experiencing white supremacy right
the answer to that the reason that that
is a an argument that we even entertain
is white supremacy right because we are
trained to center whiteness in all
spaces right i'm sorry that you feel bad
that you know i'm oppressed and maybe
you have something to do with it or
benefit from it somehow right that's a
ridiculous ridiculous argument to
entertain and the only reason we
entertain it is because rooted in
every system
the basis of those systems are white
supremacy
did anyone else have a response
as a writer
i long ago ceased to speculate on
whether any individuals are racist
i focus on the system and the results
and
if you know if the if the end result is
a a racist structure
or
has a racist effect
um
that's what i focus on i think for
intelligent discussion that's what you
know should be focused on um
and because one of the things that i
heard over and over again on interviews
whether they were npr or fox
trump voters were constantly saying
i'm for trump but i don't want to be
seen as a racist
and um
my
my view was that
i don't really care
what i care about is whether you're
about to vote for policies and politics
that will harm
untold you know untold amount of people
interesting
thank you give him a round of applause
i had her next
as i said i'm a history major and
in order to share make it a more
balanced presentation although you you
guys are the panelists but i do have
some input
when john
carlos races this of course i loved it
my mother did not like it and a lot of
her generation did not
um
and so
even with martin luther king and and
malcolm x
we
they get a much better press now
but
i remember going leaving college and
rushing down to the courthouse to listen
to malcolm x speak
and i felt like even if you didn't
even if you didn't believe in what he
believed in there were the press from
all over the world and when they asked
him a question it was like
silence
he was a a great order and a lot of
people who are liking malcolm x now
and even martin luther king right now
and i i heard him speak and it was
wonderful also
it wasn't like that and history has made
us forget
i remember when when martin was first
getting popular we called ourselves
negros
and i remember and my mother would say
colored and i it took me the longest for
her
to stop saying color you know it was
like tea it was just
but as young people
we embraced it and even the the movement
out of the south i believe started with
a lot of young people so right now
history has given it a much more
whitewash
but a lot of people did not like it and
the people that embraced these changes
were young people
people i think i was about 18 when they
had the march on washington and i wanted
to just be there i don't think
my mother would let me even even if we
had the money we didn't but she was just
afraid she didn't want to
she she lived by it'll be all right
syndrome and that's not it's not going
to be all right you have to fight and
speak up and one more thing on
kaepernick
he's adopted and my daughter's adopted
people that are adopted we all have
issues
and
he would go to places with his parents
and he would see that he was treated
differently and the fact that he's
making a million dollars or what have
you
they have to pay him
if they could get him for cheaper than
what he they would but i think that
athletes those athletes and the rest of
us who have been privileged to have
something you need to speak up
it is not always about race i remember
one time and then i'm finished um ice
cube's mother invited me and my cousin
to
watch
uh
a game in the box
and there were several people they were
all we were all her guests so
the fruit
the dessert cart came by and i said
would you like to have something she
said no no no some fool
one of her guests said well just charge
it to your son
and she said i can't do that and this
fool said well he can afford it and to
this day i just resent that i didn't say
something to that person and so as you
said you prepared i'm prepared now okay
thank you very much thank you very much
um
at this stage at this stage we are going
to have to close out the panel but
please feel free to pull aside the
speakers that you fancied the most
and i'm sorry but as the moderator i
have to close this section but thank you
for your interest and let's give our
panelists a round of applause
and thank them all and um thank you all
for coming out tonight to the california
african-american museum
and uh and let's all uh enjoy the
exhibition that's still open until nine
o'clock thank you all and have a blessed
night